started so um
representative bean if you if if you
just would get yourself ready to take a
roll
you may need to do that when i get
through reading this
um as chair of division three of the
house finance committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic in accordance with the
governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 is extended
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
is
authorized pursuant to the governor's
emergency order however in accordance
with the emergency order
i'm confirmed confirming
that we are using zoom webinar for this
remote meeting all members of the
committee and staff of the state
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through and through this platform the
public has access contemporaneously to
watch and or listen through the zoom
or alternatively through a phone and
following the directions
and links that have been provided in
every house
calendar since house calendar eight and
they're all listed on the gen
gen court webpage we
have previously given notice in those
house calendars
on how to listen in via the telephone
and we've stated that if you have
trouble
accessing this you should email us at
lba underscore
leg.state.nh.us
and if you email us letting know letting
us know that there's a problem
we will adjourn this meeting and
reschedule it
please note that if we take a vote that
will be by roll call
and i don't see representative weiler
yet
he will be here but if you would
mr uh representative bean go ahead and
take an attendance and when the member
states their
states that they're here please let us
know
who else may be in the room or house
with you
representative wallner uh mary jane
walner uh
i'm at home in concord and i'm home
alone
representative nordgren nordgren here in
hanover
in my dining room office and i'm alone
representative rogers i'm katherine
rogers i'm in concord in my apartment
and with my dog romeo
representative edwards uh representative
edwards in my home office in
auburn uh i have other people and dogs
in the house but my door is shut they
shouldn't be coming in
europe president come alone in my home
office
representative weiler not here yet
i'm representative bean i'm home in
guilford uh my
wife's in the house here somewhere with
okay so thank you um
one of the documents that uh got worked
on over the weekend
and should have been sent to all of the
committee members i believe all of you
um um but maybe representative bean has
acknowledged receipt of this it's a word
document that
uh i uh i labeled as division three
march madness
remembering back in the day when there
would actually be basketball tournaments
with people at them
um but so so our march madness
is the sprint to completing our budget
work on the 24th
it's in the calendar format that i
adopted from what
mr ripple gave us a while ago
and if you could if you could pop it
open
i'd like to just walk you through it
um so for example you'll see that
today we have scheduled
the the close out of the public health
services and then we'll hear about the
veterans home
and this afternoon or this morning later
i'd like to get us to talk about section
22 of the hb2
see if that's ready to approve then
we'll have
representative wallner who has put in a
lot of extra
work uh over the past several days
include the weekend to talk to us about
section 39 the forensic mental health
hospital
representative walner will you be ready
to do that today ma'am i don't want to
put you on the spot
i think so i'm just going to ask um i
will send kevin an email i just
i just had a couple of things that i
would ask kevin maybe to put up as a
screen share
yes ma'am and then you'll you'll note if
you're looking at the march madness
calendar i sent out
that that i put on thursday of this week
that we would
we would finish section 39 so
so you're we're not in under any
pressure today
to decide it's just great thank you
you're telling us what you got and then
we'll decide on thursday
okay fine uh
then um i'd like to get some input
on how we can do a quick sort on
um getting uh past the portions
of the budget that that we have you know
basically violent agreement about
and uh so that we can set it aside
um and then mr ripple and mr felstad
you know as i understand uh there is a
tremendous amount of work every time we
change a number anywhere in the
accounting system
it has to manually be gone and over and
typed into the system
and obviously that's prone to error
because
you have humans doing it so there's a
lot of time spent
making sure there's quality control too
so
we we want to we want to give them as
much
clerk entry work as early as possible so
that
they can move beyond it now uh represent
our representative mr ripple i just
described your process did i describe it
semi-accurately
what would you add so that we know
how how onerous a task that is i do
think you described it very accurately
so basically any change that you make we
will
need to go in and manually enter on both
the expenditure side and the funding
side
so if an item is funded by a mixture of
general funds federal funds and other
funds
we need to manually manually enter in
each one of those
so it is quite a long process and you're
right at the end of it invariably there
will be mistakes i don't think i've ever
done it without mistakes and we'll have
to hunt those down and make any
necessary changes so
depending on how many changes the
committee decides to make
potentially take a couple of days okay
so so the my point in teeing that up is
just to encourage all of us to be
thinking about
what portions of the budget that we
think will be relatively easy for us to
agree to agree on and move past
so representative norgren uh you have
your hand up
yes thank you mr chair um i think you
gave us homework
last week or the week before uh you gave
us a list of possible
departments that you thought we could
just
okay without going any more into depth
with them
and so division three uh
kathy rogers and mary jane waller and i
met
and came up with their list so just so
you know when it's time
we're ready to talk to you about that oh
that's outstanding
um if you if you've got that why don't
you
consider emailing it to all of us and
then
if there's time this afternoon we'll uh
don't don't let me quit
the adjourn the meeting until we've
talked about what you've emailed
okay good thank you thank you
and then at the end of the day um
i see us doing uh our first
reveal of uh hb1
kind of an intro representative
irf and i have spent hours and hours
talking back and forth with each other
accessing these rounds integrating
the chairman of the finance committee uh
to make sure that we're
in sync and so i think we have something
for mr or representative earth to share
with the committee
that will begin be the starting point
of our conversation with each other
about how
to invest some excess
revenues that uh fall out from the
process he used and i don't wanna
i don't wanna short change his
presentation
but i guess right up front with everyone
in the crowd
and everyone on the on on our committee
i i want you to just have it clear
that what representative irf will share
with us later
is a conversation starting point
it is not the end point of the division
three work
the end point of the division three work
will come as we approach the 24th of
march
and it'll be done with us talking to one
another
and agreeing on what we can agree on
and and just adding clarity if we
disagree on something
so so that we know what those issues are
but so don't
when you take a look at it please don't
react to it
until after representative has had a
chance to talk about it
and then so if there are no questions at
this point i think we're ready to start
the public health services
continuation does anyone have any
questions on the committee
okay not seeing any uh mr ripple
why don't you get us going where we
where we're supposed to be in the brief
okay um i'll actually i'll let karen
point you to where you're supposed to be
i think you're at the uh
you're into the budget now so you're
into the uh actual accounting units
and i think everybody's should be good
to go
okay great sorry i couldn't find the
file at first
um so where we left off uh was
accounting unit 5608 which is on page 10
cessation
so i got to remember how to read these
again so okay
so so we is this one that requires a
match
because we've got like 369 000 to the
bet 838 is there a match in here
early yes there is a match general fun
match
i'm having a hard time hearing is that
yes or no on a match
the match is typically uh 200 000
just a flat flat match
moe i forget what moe stands for but
it's kind of a minimal level of effort
that we're supposed to do we put 200 000
in and that makes us eligible for the
rest of it
so it's a 200k moe okay
are there any questions from the
yeah um you you've mentioned earlier in
your
narrative about the smoking cessation
program that it had worked very well and
you'd found good results on it
but i noticed that the funding is down
this year
if it's working so well why are you
actually it looks like the general funds
are down slightly
so i don't want to interrupt but i'm
confused it looks like the general funds
are going from 340 to 369. so the
general funds are up a little bit
it's the federal funds that are down
the federal funds were budgeted um sorry
for the delay
and hopefully you can hear me my
internet telling me it's unstable
the federal funds are budgeted at the
level that we're being advised to budget
by
the um for fiscal 20 and 21
we had some carry forward funds that we
were able to bring
like one year we didn't spend it on we
requested to bring the federal funds
forward so
the amounts for those two years have a
if you have a follow-up representative
rogers
you said you didn't spend it all why
i'd have to defer to um dr shirella if
she might have the answer
otherwise we could go back to the
program and check with them
a lot of times it's we can't get
contracts set up or
or stood up um timely for whatever the
reason may be
or if there's a vacancy in the positions
i'd i'd like you to get to us why that
money wasn't spent um
this is the second program that we found
that money we authorized wasn't spent
and i'm curious because it is a problem
in new hampshire it
is a deadly problem and you've shown
that the program works so i'm
a little bit leery if we're not using
all the money i'd like to know why so
could you get that information to the
division please
i think i can answer that question uh
representative rogers
um it's specifically related to a
contracting process
there was a delay in the contracting
process and that kind of added the
delays into spending down that funds
and what was the delay uh we
we actually had an rfp out and
the bidding process and plan getting
through the gnc process so that that was
the added
feeling
so the delay was just what we didn't
have staff enough to do it we didn't
have time
it's that the process of getting the
bits in and reviewing and getting
through
some of the back and forth on the
financial process you know
the the finalizing the budgets and
everything so that added the delay
um uh this is lisa morris good morning
everybody i uh
maybe karen would have more information
but i know there um
that uh the covid contracts were taking
up
uh quite a bit of time on the uh on the
contract unit side
uh and that may have contributed to
delays but i
uh karen you would know more information
on that
i think that's accurate lisa so this
wouldn't have been done before i mean
this budget passed before
the cove virus was active so i'm just
curious because we
seem to be finding more and more of this
that we authorize things not just in
this department
but otherwise things and they're not
done so that's why i'm curious
are there other questions here i i i
know that it's been described that this
program
is effective but i don't know how you
would measure effectiveness
beyond the number of people reached or
touched
as opposed to the number of people that
decided not to smoke i don't know how
you would measure that
so if um but uh
let's let's uh let's go ahead and go to
the next
um represent representative edwards uh
if it's if it's okay i know that dr
ella can answer that question if you
have the time but
i did want to mention that uh there was
uh 440 000 over the biennium
um of 2223 uh that was uh
identified as a prioritized need
relative to
our e-cigarette uh concerns
uh the number of adolescents who are
utilizing e-cigarettes electronic
cigarettes um so that is not reflected
here but wanted you to know that
where would that be reflected ms morris
it is not refl it is reflected i believe
yes it prioritized need in the agency
budget
so which agency what line item what
number
no meaning our agency submission budget
that we made on
september okay so
you you ask the governor to consider it
and it didn't make it into his budget
correct
i had a good weekend i have to
re-remember how we say these things
understood so representative wallner
your hand is up
yes thank you would that be um would
would there be federal money
for that or do is it 100
um general funds well those dollars that
i mentioned were
a general fund request okay
okay so are you able to with these
general funds
decide if you want to focus on
prevention
of traditional cigarettes or
e-cigarettes
or when you get the general funds is it
segregated and restricting you to only
traditional cigarettes
dr tarella can you uh can you repeat the
question
representative edwards i didn't hear
that
i want to know if you have any
restrictions on these general funds to
where if we give you general funds
if you must use them on traditional
cigarettes or do you
inherently have the flexibility
of spending it on e-cigarette
prevention efforts when we requested it
was specifically for the e-cigarette
prevention
the priority request that we made the
the to the 440 that miss
dr morris has mentioned it's basically
meant for the youth prevention
for the e-cigarettes yes but we do not
have restriction
on the use of general funds uh but we
use those general funds
for uh for uh for both
traditional tobacco and e-cigarettes
okay so so you have inherent flexibility
in this even though that
there's a 200 000 moe against the
federal money
even that 200 000 is flexible
is that true it's it's specifically
macro prevention
activities yes okay
uh representative wallner you have a
okay your hand is down i think we can
move on
the next one is account 5659 which is
this is a relatively small amount of
general funds
in a relatively large amount of federal
funds is that
170 a required match or an moe
it is a required match stated
okay i'm using the words differently uh
just so you're track we're tracking on
communication
if it's an moe i think we have to
we have to spend that money before we
get the first nickel of federal money
that's distinct from a match in my view
a match in my view has a
ratio correlated with it so that if we
give two dollars we're eligible for four
dollars
so so this 170 is that an moe
it's called a match in the notice of
but it is more similar to what we would
define in moe
it sometimes the federal government
likes to call it something different
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna consider
that 170 in moe
am i wrong that's fine
the next one is 70 45 which is wise
women
this is a grant that started this year
we submitted an item to fiscal committee
uh very recently so that's why it's not
showing anything an adjusted authorized
there
okay so this is just federal money
welcome representative weiler
um we're we're in progress we've talked
about
just two accounts so far you haven't you
haven't missed much discussion on the
accounting
thank you
okay so this is all this is all federal
money
so this is this is a comment i would
make to the committee
um and that is as as
earlier when i was talking about uh
the opportunity for us to agree on
things that we could remove
from future considerations so that the
rep
mr ripple and feldstein still can
put it to bed and not worry about it
these programs
where it's all federal money i i would
tend to put into that
bucket of we don't need to consider it
further for division three
and so this would be a good example of
of of that rule of thumb if it's all
federal
let's let's just accept it and move on
is there
and i'm taking a little diversion but is
there any discussion to that or is there
any disagreement with that point of view
from the committee it's the way we've
usually dealt
okay representative rogers your hand is
up well i have a problem in the um
the funds for the tobacco prevention and
cessation that the governor um
can we can we pause that conversation
and finish this one right now which is
i thought you were talking about both of
those funds i'm sorry
i'm only talking about wise women as an
example
of an account that only has federal
money
okay sure we can
reserve that then i just meant i thought
you were talking about all of them
no just the ones that only have federal
money
okay okay now you
you still have a comment on tobacco
cessation so we can go back to that if
you'd like
no i can wait until we i thought you
wanted us to approve that one
now oh no okay come on then
okay um so we were uh
at wise woman i i think i think we can
go on unless there are any questions
arthritis
can we just look at the funding line for
a quick moment
are there any are there any questions on
this um this
i'm not i'm not seeing any we can go on
okay
the next accounting unit is 70 47 which
is community collaboration
is this where the prioritized needs are
lisa yes i'm here on the same side
not in her head so there are several
prioritized needs with this accounting
unit
all um what has been referred to
uh in the last legislative session and
publicly is parental assistance dollars
um they are preventative dollars for
our families can we
can we go to the funding line just so we
have
context so so
am i reading this right that this
community collaboration is 100
federal funding that's correct um
[Music]
the prioritized needs are 100 general
funds though
what what are your prioritized needs how
much
i believe it was around 1.2 million
for this particular so you want 1.2
million for community collaboration in
general funds
yes over the biennium so six hundred
thousand each year
this was in the list that the governor
um sent over as well
that he did what too i'm you faded just
a little bit and i'm feeling deaf today
um it was in the list that the governor
sent over in the letter to the house
and that you're referring to the letter
where he said hey
it's okay if you spend more money in
that that was just
it was the letter that the governor sent
to the house
okay so are there any other questions
what would what would you do with 600
000 more a year how many personnel would
you hire and what would they be doing
uh dr tirella would you like to take
that question
uh we are not hiring people the funding
is going towards
three of our contracts specifically
focused on
collaborations and uh the all the
going to the communities nothing is
staying with us and the funding is
specifically for the three
agencies that are focused on the
community collaborations
and one other uh funding is also going
to family connections it's the
through the department connection the
funding will be going to them
to support like the for specifically for
families uh to provide parental
education
uh and um for who are the
family connections one is specifically
with the financial education
and programs for resident consumption
state prison
the other the other amount which i
talked about community collaboration is
very much focused on our funding that's
coming through federal funds
so those will be going to the three
communities
side can you uh talk about what exactly
they'll be doing with those dollars
you know um i i can provide some details
uh these are these grants are very much
this funding is very much focused on
families with children with uh
children with zero to eight so we're
looking at how to create communities and
connections for those families with
um to reduce the barrier to access so
connecting them all the resources that
the families can access to
so these could be parent education
classes crisis support
warm handouts to child care or mental
health or substance use
or dental health or even economic
support for those families
so that's what the focus is on
so flipping it around if i'm ahead of a
household
the impact that these dollars would have
is that the people in
dhhs and in other community
organizations
would be better resourced in order to
make me aware
of the services that are available and
help coach me on which services i should
apply for
yes it would also help connect you to
those services and the
goal is to reduce the rates of child
maltreatment so we're talking about
families in need
and if i can just jump in um if you
recall back to last week when we were
talking
this is a better connection to some of
those home visiting programs i was
talking about
and in particular we had a really
successful pilot program
for substance exposed infants so again
getting those families early on
um connecting with prenatal providers
making sure
from the moment that baby is born that
they're connected to the resources they
need
and the parents have the support they
need for appropriate parenting
understanding child development and in
particular with those substance exposed
okay for one i had children
that seemed like a lot of that sort of
communication and coordination would
come
from the office of the ob gyn that would
have follow-up visits with us to check
on well baby status
what why is that not adequate
these days trisha do you want to take
that
sure so what we're finding is actually
that those medical providers
are coming and really depending on our
family resource centers in particular
um in our communities to do that sort of
dated um week to week home visiting
supportive help that they don't have
time for within the context of those
well baby visits
those well baby visits may happen in the
early days you know once a month and
in these programs what we find is that
we have some evidence-based programs
um that have home visits that start
weekly and we can connect them to the
resources that's needed
provide the modeling and support around
appropriate parenting again if you think
about those substance exposed infants
those babies
come out and they may have some
additional needs making sure they're
connected with early supports and
services if if that's required if
there's an actual
developmental issue going on and really
making sure those families are connected
to their communities
so the doctors have asked us to work
hand in hand with them
to make sure that those families are
supported really so that
we prevent child maltreatment and the
negative health outcomes that we want
you know again if you recall when we
were talking about home visiting
you know sometimes many times we start
prenatally and we're even looking
at um the birth outcomes there ensuring
that folks
stick with their tobacco cessation we
know many families have a number of
of things that they're stressed over and
tobacco is one of them
and we were just talking about the
tobacco program and and we know that
pregnant women need
a lot of support to stay to stay quit
not only during pregnancy but even
postpartum
and doctor tarella said that is 600 000
there were no additional personnel
that would be funded by that 600
thousand is that
is that accurate i know she's a
physician and not a resource manager
is that did she say she's both she's
both
um but that is correct it goes right out
to the communities
okay i are there any other questions in
okay the next one is uh 5896 which is
the home visiting grant this is also
an area where there is a prioritized
need of 464 thousand dollars a year
which was also on the list that the
governor provided to the house
per year so that's almost a million over
the biennium
yes 927 thousand
we look at peak ahead at what the
breakdown between federal
or wherever i did yep it's 100 federal
yes you sort of go in and out when
you're when you're talking unless you're
okay i'm trying to i think my microphone
is
forward halfway across my desk so i'll
try to lean forward
are there any other questions from
is that volume uh okay representative
erf
yes that's good you can maintain that
yes okay
i don't want to yell at people um all
right
so we can continue all right the next
one
is 5906 which is suid
you have any prioritized needs in this
account
nope i think we've talked about all of
the public health prioritized themes at
this point if i remember correctly
maybe one more yeah i think there's one
more in the laboratory
oh i need a web that's right are there
any questions on the
remind me of the acronym s-u-i-d
i can't even imagine being a parent and
having that happen
can i ask a question about that sure
this isn't budget specific but
um so i've experienced this
and my understanding is that a long time
ago back in the 90s
that you no longer provide things like
the
report to the parents is that true
uh i i can check on that but we do talk
with the parents our office of chief
medical examiner reaches out
provides them all their grief resources
um and
that that's what we do but i can check
on whether that information about
autopsy is limited now or not
i missed that word when you said you
reached out to them to discuss what
grief resources the resources for us to
support them
during that grief time like it could be
um
okay okay i understand the grief
resources um i'm asking more about the
the actual cause of death resources as
opposed to that
we joined the sids uh group at the time
which i hope is still active
and it was a big help no doubt about it
but i'm curious also about the um
the cause of death reports we can follow
up on that one uh most of that
information goes from our office of
chief medical examiner
office and i can check on that thank you
representative earth we're so sorry for
your loss
well thank you i appreciate that well
there wasn't trying to draw sympathy
okay all right so i think we're on
6048 wic infrastructure that's correct
and then uh what are the general funds
requests there
are there any questions here by the
committee
saying none let's let's go to the next
okay the next one is 1227 which is
combined chronic disease
all right yeah just a quick question
sorry
i noticed some of these accounts karen
that are just 100 federal still have a
general line whereas others don't is
that because of
points in time they've had general
funding that's possible
okay um yes that would be my guess that
either in
20 or 21 there were some general funds
there sometimes inappropriately
or incorrectly i should say maybe you
know
okay the next one is 1228 which is the
this one is is entirely or pretty
it's it's it's all general funds or
there's some transfer from other
agencies
okay and then this is
it's it's a flat funded from the prior
year
was that is that intentional what's
going on
in this area or we
are we serving the same number of people
or the call volumes going up or we
is how are things going here
uh go ahead
go ahead uh yes the call volumes have
been going up during the covert time
specifically um uh there was a 24
increase from 2019 and largely due to
pandemic about cleaning and all other
questions um in 2020 we had around nine
at close to 9 300 human exposure so
different kind of substances
so that's that's what we they have done
and a lot of prevention resources during
pandemic time so
related to poisonings has the labs fact
sheets about
what's what's the right way of cleaning
and all other things
yes there has been increased but we have
representative nordgren question yes
thank you
um do we still service
maine with our poison control center
i believe we used to it's a northern new
england poison center but it it doesn't
yes it's based in maine
uh uh but it serves new hampshire
specifically
thank you for pointing that out uh
representative nordron
um all right uh i don't see any other
the next one is 1869 which is uh
oh do you want to explain what that is
that is too many acronyms for me
that's fine i can tell uh it's called
national uh national violent death
registry
we can move on how are we doing uh
ms rounds are are we are we uh
we've got an hour or so or longer what
do you think to get through public
health
um it's probably about another hour we
were a little bit slow starting off but
i think we're moving along now so
um 33 86 early hearing
i knew detention didn't make sense there
so
okay this is all federal funds it is
who are we testing with that are we
testing
only children who show special
characteristics or are we doing 100
well baby what what who's the target
population it's universal screening so
we do screen for all the kids
all the babies born in new hampshire and
then based on their need then we follow
up on their
uh if they have uh some hearing uh
deficiency then we follow up on their
families and connect them as well as to
the providers and others
assume the follow-up is coming from a
different budget though
yes there are two newborn hearing
3387 newborn hearing well how many
how many how many babies get tested for
in that federal program per year i i
heard you say all of them but what is
that
in new hampshire it's around we have
around 12 000 births happening in new
hampshire so basically we are looking at
around 12 000 babies
for screening and then follow-up is
around uh because the follow-up we do up
to
age of three years so it's around 400
very good let's talk about 33.87
unless i don't see any questions this is
also 100
federal
okay do we have any sense of how long
the federal government will
want to continue funding these two lines
is this is this something that we get an
early indicator
on whether or not they think this should
be transitioned to the state at some
point
we haven't gotten anything from them yet
i
i haven't seen them changing uh any of
their
thought process on how this is funded at
this point of time
or how it should be funded in future
education
we're dropping the federal government
looks like they're
they they went up they spiked in 21 but
uh from 20 and that they're returning
to their previous levels why why did
they spike for a year
do we know um sometimes they have extra
funding so they provide
us uh saying like this is an extra
dollars or funding that's available can
for the states so that's how what
happened
entwined in that 2021 timeline and now
we are back to our regular
our regular funding stream
are there any questions on this line
item
i'm not i'm not seeing any so we can go
on
3396s uh
wick implementation uh which is no
longer in use
so then moving down to 3397 is the
okay um i'm sorry you jumped right when
i was
okay so we've got on the cancer registry
um in 20 we had zero
general funds and we put 150
in and 21 and we're increasing that a
little bit
what what what's the story here why why
did we
get into this with general funds when
go ahead dr torella uh
i'm not sure why it is not reflecting
but we always had general funds in the
cancer registry because it's required
under the
moa has an uh state fund match state
match
and um not sure why we are seeing some
um the fiscal year 20 may have closed
incorrectly or it could be that the
general funds ended up being matched
by cost allocation but actually
i would have to double double check that
karen yes okay
so when you're double checking this
would you give us the exact
match percentage requirement
absolutely
i'm assuming that um we might want to
call it an moe
chairman okay good if it's an moe i want
to know versus the match
okay you got it
accepting my simple terminology
all right um we
can continue all right 50 40 is opioid
surveillance
what are they doing they drop they drop
theirs a lot
a lot of drop in the federal funds
so are we seeing a decrease in the
federal prio
well that's hard to say because they
started at 324 in fy 20
and then multiply that by 10 times or
more
i think and chile correct me if i'm
wrong but i think there was unspent
grant in fiscal year 20
that may be being reflected in 21.
definitely we got
um our our first year award was uh
smaller um we got a a bigger award in
the middle of 20.
um we did go to fiscal committee and get
it budgeted but
we were working on standing up the
programs and the contracts so it didn't
get
expended all in 20. so 21 is
at the level that moving forward what
our award is
or yeah representative wallner you have
you're unmute sorry about that um i see
that the contracts are
about five about half a million dollars
less each year
what kinds of contracts are we not going
to be having
in 22 and 23. we
um i can answer that question um it's
not going to impact any of our current
contracts they will be
all level funded as you can see the 2021
is the time
when we had some extra dollars extra
funding that actually went into
uh the contracts but everyone is
funded and no changes on their contract
lines
i'm not seeing any more questions we can
go to
7048 i think is next
yes which is a pediatric
mental health access and this is 100
federal
there any questions here
i'm not seeing any we can go
okay the next one is uh 1079 which is
pediatric cancer survey which was a
one-time expenditure in fiscal year 21.
uh then right after that is 34.87 which
is
uh maternal mortality which is 100
percent
questions from maternal mortality
this is the death of the mother and
childbirth is that what that is
generally
up to one year of uh after pregnancy or
after delivery how many of those do we
have a year
we um we are very lucky in our state our
numbers are very low
they are less than um they're very low
compared to the rest of the country less
than 10
i mean if we're having 12 000 kids or
are we losing
less than 10 moms you think yes less
than 10 actually
the next one is chronic disease asthma
i'm not seeing any okay the next one
is 74-23 which is senior nutrition
federal
so we're spending we're shifting we plan
to shift
a lot of the money to grants for public
assistance and relief
and away from contracts from for program
services
so is this is this is an accounting
cleanup or a program change
yes this is the change that i've talked
about where we are moving it
uh to better track sub-recipient
contracts
for our single audit thank you for doing
that
uh what's next uh so i would just
mention
that that is the last accounting unit in
this bureau so thank you
uh dr shirella for being here and for
your help
um and lisa who's the next euro chief
that should come over for infectious
disease
so that would be the best daily
thank you uh dr terella we have beth dr
daley best
dad great
okay uh so the first one in this bureau
is 2 2 2 2 which is the
ryan white part b this is 100 federal
funds
it is yes so how are we doing with
hiv stats are they have they trended
down or are they
are we still experiencing hiv and
worrisome levels uh
uh dr daley is on on the zoom and she
can answer that question for you
great yes good morning everyone thank
you mr chairman for that question so
hiv we do continue to identify new
infections each year it's
actually become pretty stable and
plateaued here in new hampshire we have
between 25
and 50 new cases identified each year in
new hampshire
and in terms of people living with hiv
and aids it's about 1200 to 1300 people
in new hampshire and those are the
people that we're serving
through the different contracts that we
have in place so let's say
it's between you just said it he's just
said we have about 15 to 25 a year
what what is what's the primary disease
vector
is it is it still unprotected sex is it
uh
generational pass from mom to baby or
what what
what's the disease vector great question
so primarily who we are seeing
become infected with hiv currently are
men who have sex with men so it's sexual
transmission
and then we also do have some
transmission occurring through
shared needles um for drug use and it's
very
uncommon actually to have the mom pass
to the baby although we do have
you know one case happen every few years
where we've documented that occurring
and that's because
we try to get as many people who get
diagnosed with hiv on effective
treatment so that
kind of thing does not happen as long as
that mom's on her antiviral
um therapy then there's it's unlikely
the baby will
will become infected well that's good
news so
so in this ryan fund is this
uh i i shouldn't be able to look at it
faster than i
am but is this um it says care
assistance
so of the is this meant to go to the 15
to 25 to augment their health care
to deal specifically with their hiv
problems
yes and so it actually serves about 1200
to 1 300 people who are living with hiv
and aids in new hampshire so that
25 to 50 are the number of new
infections that we add each year
but there's it's obviously a lifelong
chronic condition now and so people will
live
with it for their lifetime and will need
to continue to receive
that effective care to keep them alive
and so
there's a number of different accounting
units here that are for different hiv
services
and this one does provide financial
assistance to people who need it for
they provide that care for them
financial assistance
in what type are we helping them pay
medical bills prescriptions are we
helping them
with housing or something else what what
what kind of assistance are we giving
sure so we're a payer
of last resort so what we first try to
do is connect people
um to health insurance that they may
already be
eligible for we will connect them to
medicaid
and we might help them pay their
premiums or co-pays if they can't afford
that
and then we do pay for their
um their medical bills as well anything
that's outstanding
or if they're completely uninsured but
again we try to connect them to medicaid
first
and so it provides that funding for
their
their treatment and also some wraparound
services we have case managers who
assist these people with
getting access to different services in
the state it might include for example
transportation
to their um to their medical
appointments
there is housing money available for
people living with hiv
and aids but that's in a different
accounting unit and overseen by the
bureau of housing
homelessness and housing at dhhs
so have we gotten a number of hiv
transmissions that are associated with
unprotected sex have we gotten that
number down low enough to where
people know they shouldn't be having
unprotected sex they just
are doing it anyways or have we kind of
maxed out
the potential of prevention
um well i'd hate to say that we've maxed
out the potential of
prevention but we have plateaued right
so we continue to still see transmission
occurring i think a lot of people
obviously know about hiv and the risks
from risky behavior however there's
different barriers that come into play
that prevent people
from being able to make good choices all
the time and so
we're actually there's new technologies
available new medications that have come
on the market where
people can actually take a medicine if
they every day if they want to prevent
i'm getting hiv if they are in a risky
group um so there's new
options for us to try and prevent hiv
but i'd like to think that we
we could not have any hiv too but
certainly it has plateaued and
yeah zero is the goal but yeah
all right uh are there any questions
other than mine in this area
uh representative norgren thank you mr
chair
um i was just wanting to maybe suggest
obviously it's your decision mr chair
that
we okay all these uh
departments or we just had federal
funding i think
we'd have a great feeling of
accomplishment
and it would make us our list longer
that we have to go back and look at
so i i agree with what your
intent is there the the process i was
anticipating
is was just slightly different i i was
asking
i just this morning asked mr ripple to
create a list
of all of the accounts that are federal
funds only
so that we once we got a documented list
in front of us we could review it
overnight just to make sure we're
comfortable with it
and that we would do one vote on all of
those uh but
but i i thought we may want to see
a list to help document exactly what
we're voting on
that sounds like a good plan thank you
very much
thank you all right
so i think we're ready for 2223
which is also related to hiv and
shelly where did these funds come from
good question
what what is a private local fund dr
daly would you like to address this
dart these are coming from um this
the boston public health they've
received
funding for their ema their metropolitan
area
and because new hampshire abuts that
region part of our new hampshire
counties are
in their ema and they provide
us funding uh to help serve the
community that is part of their larger
region the boston region and so we are
able to use these
funds to serve people who are in
hillsborough
brackingham and stratford counties
so that's all great i i just wonder as
tedious as miss rounds is if if this is
properly labeled it sounds like the
boston ema
may be getting federal money and then uh
sharing it with us
um and that would make that government
funds
not private or did i misunderstand
so that it would be federal to the city
of boston
and then it's private local funds to us
so it's the city of boston's
responsibility to audit
us as their sub-recipient for these
funds
the federal government would audit the
city of boston
so we're considering the city of boston
a governmental
entity a private source of local funds
correct okay
i don't see any other questions we could
do 229
all federal right no agency a little bit
of agency income and
the general funds that are there in
fiscal year 20 um should not have been
the way i'm reading that that's a huge
amount
five million dollars on agency income
and very little federal oh yes i'm sorry
i read it backwards
no i i said it wrong to begin with i
think i i
i started it wrong so
so as i understand this money
as well you tell me what this money is
where are these rebates coming from i
think they come from the pharmaceutical
companies
but on what basis they do so uh recall
that we
pay for people's hiv medications
and normally you know patients might get
rebates back for you for purchasing
those
drugs but because we're the ones who are
actually paying for it we get those
rebates back
paid to us it's obviously a substantial
amount of money that pays for the
majority of
our hiv programs so where we do get some
federal funding that you've seen
through the different accounting units
we're required actually first to use
our drug rebate money before we tap into
the federal funding
and so this funds a substantial portion
of our program a number of different
um positions and a lot of our contracts
it's basically like reinvesting back
into the program
so thank you for that so i'm looking at
expense
item five three zero drug rebates
and that's an expense item that looks
like it wants to be an income line
and and is it is it pro what is that 530
paying for
shelly could you help me out with this
class
yes so in this class is um where the
payments
are made to our contracted vendor for
the actual prescriptions
as well as the other services that dr
daley spoke of
um that when we're required to pay the
rebates first
the enrollees i i know that's not the
right word i'm sorry
um for their services out of this line
as well
before we are able to move over to the
federal funds that we get
um in accounting unit 2222
so basically that class is used to
purchase additional
pharmaceuticals i'm going to come off of
that area
but it sounds like there's a lot of cash
moving out
from uh private hands back to private
hands so
i'll come to you representative weiler
in just a second sir
um i i'm just hoping that this is
got great internal controls and great
auditing around it because it just feels
like it's
a cash rich business but representative
weiler do you have a
yes i recall in the past some of the
budgets we have used as much as
balancing the budget are we still
getting considerable
rebates from the companies so i think
you're thinking about medicaid drug
rebates
um and we do still get substantial drug
rebates there
and those are budgeted in the medicaid
budget these drug rates that our
drug rebates are specific to the hiv
drugs that we purchase
so those get those get budgeted
somewhere else
okay are there any other questions
because if there aren't i think we can
go to 5170 disease control
yes
which is on mostly on page 1072.
so we're back to using general funds
here
yes shelly is there a match
so the federal money is just brought us
to for this program and then
we believe that we need to augment it
with general funds
is that is that a proper way of saying
it
so the general funds that are in this
account are
to support disease control emergencies
there's i think a hundred thousand
dollars
that's there in case we have some type
of emergency or outbreak that we need to
respond to that and we have
funds available to be able to mount that
response
because a lot of our federal funding is
really used for programmatic
work and so that fun those funds are
available sometimes we don't use them we
obviously won't use them if we don't
need them we've happened to have a
number of different emergencies over the
last few years that we've used
for example or during our hepatitis a
outbreak we've also used those funds
during
our pfas response to help pay for
testing
um for the individuals who are impacted
by those the water contamination
and then we also have funds in here
available to support
tuberculosis treatment for people who
require financial assistance if they
have tuberculosis which is highly
communicable and we obviously need
people to get
treated for it and so again like our hiv
financial assistance we will also
help to pay for people's tuberculosis
medications until they're cured so that
they're not
transmitting their infection i i thought
we were on the cusp of
eradicating tb um
yes come back been working on
tuberculosis control for
a long day you know actually centuries
right
um but no it does still exist we
primarily see it in people who have
international travel
or or who have lived internationally but
there are you know hundreds of people
each year in new hampshire who um have
been
exposed and test you know have a skin
test showing that they have
uh have been exposed at some point in
their lifetime and we want them to get
treated to prevent
actually becoming ill with active tb
where they can cough and
make people sick but we have about 20
cases of active tb
at what point do the are our new
newly arrived refugees get tested for tb
do they get tested for tb while they're
in their home country or
do we wait until they get to new
hampshire
they do get tested before they um
arrive in the case of like refugees
right and then they also get tested
all right uh are there any other
i'm not seeing anything you can go okay
the next one is 5174
i just need to spend more of that in my
yard
that's not very much money what do you
what do you what are you really doing
with forty thousand dollars
for a state this big so the way that
we're using these funds
is to purchase reagents laboratory
testing regions for our public health
lab
to be able to do all the testing it does
for both mosquitoes
and and humans we do get a very small
amount of
funding from the federal government but
it's just you know i think it's less
than ten thousand or ten thousand
dollars
it's really only enough to test humans
and what we need to do is test those
mosquitoes so we have early
indicators and warnings of when um we
are finding the different viruses
tripoli and west nile virus
out in the community so we can alert the
public
that that's the lab costs so we know
what kind of mosquito diseases are
correct this account used to be bigger
and it included some reimbursement to
communities to be able
to spray like you were just mentioning
but over time that has been
reduced through the budgeting process to
okay coming down the next one is
5177 vaccine insurers
and uh this is one of those accounting
units that closed incorrectly there
should not have been general funds in
so are we on 5178 then sure
that's the immunization i'm sorry yeah
because there are no
there are no funds in the governor's
budget for this right
177 vaccines insurers there's a
revolving fund but there are no
general funds going in to replenish it
correct
correct it's just the um money that
i don't remember where but from the
insurers
who pay into a purchasing pool so that
we can purchase
vaccines that reduce cost off the cdc
contract and we purchase all vaccines
for children
in the state so okay i'm just gonna
throw
a comment that a constituent made at me
about
six months ago she
she believed that
we had a profit motive
as a state to over vaccinate children
because every time we vaccinated a child
we would get money from the
pharmaceutical companies
and as she described it she was
convinced
that there's a profit motive here that
is is potentially causing bad state
behavior
with causing us to want to over
vaccinate
how would you respond to that
constituent well i would say that is not
true
uh there's no uh profit or funding
that's provided
based on how many kids were vaccinating
there's no kickbacks from pharmaceutical
companies and our only interest in
vaccinating children is to prevent
okay if you so but if you boil down what
she said to me the part that still seems
to have some truth into it
is that the the vaccine
companies the suppliers are
giving us some amount of money based on
the total number of kids
we have vaccinated is that true or false
that is false these funds are coming
from the insurance companies
who are paying into a purchasing pool so
that they
can reduce their costs associated with
paying for vaccination for kids
it's not coming from pharmaceutical
companies we don't get any money from
pharmaceutical companies relative to
vaccines
and we cannot use these funds for any
purpose other than that
hurt your strictest sons yeah correct
representative you have a question sir
oh yes sir thank you mr german so are
they paying
in voluntarily because it's less
expensive for them to
pay to the state and then the state can
get a better price on the vaccines
rather than them having to
buy them individually for each child
yes so there's a state law that is on
the books that creates the new hampshire
vaccine association where the insurers
come together
and pay in they are assessed uh a fee
based on their accessible lives um
and they there's a whole feeding process
that happens where they're paying into
it
um so that we can purchase these
vaccines
it i don't believe that it's their
participation
is necessarily mandatory though i'd have
to go back and look at that but the
insurers like this program
and they participate in it because it
caught saves about 10 million dollars
each year in their
in vaccine costs just for the vaccine
alone
that's why it's wondering and so this is
the savings because you can buy it in
bulk as opposed to them
we can purchase it off of the federal
cdc contract
which is offer substantial savings which
they cannot do
correct thank you representative
weiler i think it's also true that
some people's health insurance plans pay
for this
for them to go and have these shots but
this way the shot would be less
expensive
to the insurance company paying for it
than if they didn't
correct
so uh miss rounds as i look at
is i look at where we are in the
document
i see an elevator bar that looks like
it's about 60 percent of the way down
are we finished when we get all the way
to the bottom or we finish somewhere in
between
here and the bottom and we're finished
way before that
i have a lot of extra pages in this pdf
of things that are at the end of the
budget
plus public health is probably
like starts somewhere shortly after the
middle of our budget
so we're done at page 1097 we're
currently on page
1074 so we only have about another 20
pages
super thank you uh
5178 immunization program
yes
we're bumping up the general fund
contribute
contribution to the immunization program
a lot is
is what what is driving the increase
in immunization effort
i i mean obviously coved i mean
obviously
but i'm assuming that's covered by
federal money to pay for
shelly could you speak specifically to
the general funds is this
due to the loss of federal funds through
medicaid
i can't answer that question dr nelly
i'm not aware of loss of medicaid funds
okay i thought it might be related to
okay so i know what the federal funds
are for and there's a
echo i'm sorry i don't know if you're
the federal fund the general funds i'm
sorry it's primarily federally funded
the general funds that are in there
fund both our maintenance on our
immunization ordering system and vaccine
registry and it also funds um
a small amount of purchasing vaccines
as a contribution to the the all
the payer program that i had just
mentioned um there's an expectation that
the state contributes some amount of
funds
to help purchase vaccines as a state
insurer what i'd like to what i'd like
to do dr daley
uh is is uh suspend talking about this a
little bit
and and maybe come back to it and give
you guys a chance to
to really plow into it and make sure you
know what
what you're what what we're doing here
because
i'm looking at the federal funds going
up substantially from 2020
and then i'm looking at the general fund
going up way more than substantially
from 2020 and so this program is growing
rapidly both with federal and general
funds
and i would just like to know what is
driving that growth rate
and what's next what are is this trend
going to continue into the next budget
or are we
dealing with something transitional so
we can get you that follow-up
information okay
so maybe maybe we could just arrange a
phone call or something
um i think we can provide it all in
writing
it looks like it's primarily due to a
new temporary full-time position
and an increase in line 103 so we'll get
you what that
actually is and what it's for all right
so you'll follow up with us
sure the next one is 5179 hospital
acquired
infections and there are no general
yes so what happens with this account it
funds our hospital acquired infections
program we're required to
try to secure federal funds before we
feed the health care facilities to pay
for this program
and that's what the other funds are here
the agency income funds is a fee system
and so over time there's been quite a
bit of fluctuation in terms of what cdc
is funding it started off
when this program first started that it
was primarily federally funded and then
cdc decreased their funding and they
unfunded a few of our positions that we
then had to
pay for through fees and now they have
instilled more funding into the program
and we've been able to
um to pay for the positions again
through federal funds
thank you great explanation
what's next uh 5084 is ebola that
account has been closed out
prevention
okay so to what extent does this program
overlap with the family planning dollars
that has
a small piece of it dedicated to std
prevention
so um and i don't know if psy or trish
want to chime in on how the
how the this overlaps with family
planning but
um these our funds are really targeted
specifically to
stds they're identifying them through
testing and then
investigating the individual cases we do
some prevention work but it's primarily
around the control of
identity you know once we identify those
infections and then we investigate them
we do work in partnership with the
family planning program to make sure
that
we're not duplicating efforts and that
so so even though the word says
prevention
it sounds like most of the money you're
spending is really on
on treatment
yes and identifying testing
identification and then
investigating those cases and you know
trying to do disease control work around
them
drop in general funds here is is that
intentional
or or is there a priority's need that's
uh the drop in general funds i believe
is the
we had a prioritized need that we had in
the last
budget cycle that was funded and then
it's being unfunded
in this budget is that right shelly
yes we didn't put it forward for the
biennium
i do have a question about std still
does does the department maintain
a dashboard so that
everyone can see how what kind of stds
are in new hampshire and what the trends
are
for increase or decrease um
is there is there a place that people
can go
to for them to get visibility into the
std situation
yes we do have uh static data reports
not necessarily an
interactive dashboard that are available
on our website we produce a monthly
report as well as a more comprehensive
five-year report on stds and hiv
and those are available on our website
we can send you the link
afterwards you know i'm more concerned
that that
information is accessible to high school
nurses and it's getting out into the
high school population
so that kids are being warned that this
stuff is real
and being in that age group i think they
need to hear that a lot
so i'm just curious the extent to which
we are
actively broadcasting to the audience
of high school students is it is is it
is it getting or is this message getting
through
i don't want to scare kids i just want
to know how them know what's going on
i do think that they cover these topics
in um
you know in health education programs in
schools honestly we see stds across the
lifespan we do have the highest numbers
of chlamydia for example in 15 to 24
year olds but there's a great deal of
education
that is happening and it really comes
down to you know personal
behavior choices and i would just add
i would just add that our family
planning programs this is where that
really comes in where
um individuals are receiving care
they're getting tremendous amount of
education at that point
around how to reduce their risk we also
have a pretty robust social media um
work
right now um again sort of aiming at
that younger
and as well as an older population about
risks around
sexually transmitted diseases we also
have some other work
in cytralas dr triala's group around
a program called the pregnancy
prevention program or the prep program
and within that is a significant amount
of education again focused at a younger
population
good good i i i just remember
hearing it once in a gym class
and never hearing it again in high
school and so
i you know this is kind of more of the
constant drum beat
seems like it may be effective but times
have changed representative edwards
heard me
times have changed i i think somebody
else has mentioned that to me
[Laughter]
my kids for example okay
so um i think are there any other
questions on 75
36 all right
okay uh 50 22
is zika preparedness that grant has
ended
uh moving down to 50 93 adult
immunization
pphf also has ended
the same thing with 5094 syndrome
surveillance
so moving down to public health crisis
response 70
keep going okay uh
so first i would just say thank you dr
daly for joining us uh i
know how busy you are and i appreciate
you taking the time to
thank you thank you dr valley yeah thank
you so much i really appreciated
your your answers um
and then uh
[Music]
lisa is christine yes dr bean
uh is on if you would allow her and
just bring her in now
just give her a second so that um she
all right great so the first one is 1835
which is new hampshire
it's epidemiology laboratory capacity
all right okay the next one
is 1878 which
is the um lab equipment fund
this is also um this is actually a
revolving
fund shelly what's the source of funds
um fees that come into the lab
so i recalled somewhere in our briefings
that we had
some significantly aging lab equipment
and we needed
a lot of replacement is that this
area is this activity um it
is an accounting unit a little further
down that we have a prioritized need
thank you for remembering representative
edwards
i can't treat patients but i can buy
okay the next accounting unit is 3063
the association of public health labs
here
now are these paid by
pathologists or in places that employ
pathologists who's paying for these
this is the association of public health
labs who provide some project-based
funding for us there's an association we
have membership of as do all the
state public health laboratories
so who is a member of that for example
i i can add to it if you'd like me to
our
public health laboratory is a member of
the association of public health
laboratories
we pay an annual dues as a state member
the state of new hampshire is a member
and there are oftentimes
funds available for special projects for
us to
implement new types of testing that they
are
able to support us to do
okay i'm just looking at the 174 000
and as small as new hampshire is i'm
just wondering
if these dues are are are really onerous
to the members but these
i don't believe that's not our dues no
yeah these aren't dues these are money
this is much sent to us for projects
right oh okay so like if you go to the
the next page so the private local funds
these are these are not dues correct
no these are funds that we could um have
access to to implement projects
um it could be a training for a
laboratory
yes it's a revenue source that's correct
somebody's paying it i was just trying
to get my arms around who
is paying it the association is so the
association that we are part of that we
pay dues to be part of
then gives us money back to run projects
okay great are there any other questions
here
all right are we at 51.26
yes which is the ebola eos elc which
ended in
21 so moving right down to 79.66
which is the public health laboratory
which is
also where the prioritized need is the
prioritized need is for 50 000
in general funds for 22 and 100 000 for
general funds and 23
all of which would be for lab equipment
is it because there are new things we
can test for
or are we replacing old equipment to
uh dr beanie do you want to answer that
sure
i would say that it's for both of those
things so we need to maintain
the infrastructure and re replace
aging equipment and instruments
one example of that we had this year was
the deionized water systems in our
laboratory or di water
that we need to maintain that
infrastructure in order to keep the
lab operations uninterrupted
so in addition to that we do need to
purchase new instrumentation and
modernize the laboratory as new methods
become available
much of that funding in many cases is
available through federal
funds but not all of it so
it's for both aging instruments and
modernization
both okay so
um i see general funds of 3.836
million you you would like that to be
3.9 million
is that what your prioritized need would
do am i hearing you right
that's an addition it's an additional
000 over the biennium
like it was 50 in the first year 100 in
the second
that's correct uh
laboratory um uh repairs
new instrumentation is uh very very
expensive
um uh different than uh
other other kinds of uh equipment
worked in the radiology world but i i
kept an eye on what was going on
in pathology it is expensive stuff yeah
all right well great uh are there
questions here
for from the committee we're back into
general funds here and it's
it's not an insignificant amount
i just see the i see the 800 000 roughly
a little less i guess
general fund increase i think i'm
reading that right
but i'm just having a hard time picking
up where that is up above i see there's
a slight
decrease in the some of the agency
income
and a pretty big deal oh it's in the d
this in the general fund's decreased no
there is a decrease there in the federal
funds and this is this isn't
all cost allocated federal funds there's
no
um there's no direct
grant federal grant to this area so
these are allocated federal funds from
other areas in public health
for work that the lab is doing um
and the allocation changed on the
positions based on the work that they're
doing
that's one of those things that's
controlled by the higher-ups people
higher than you
yes or at least it's
yeah it's the thing that's controlled by
our our cost allocation plan and
um yes thank you
so ms rounds for for the 150k
over the biennium yes would you
just email us the list of what would be
purchased and where it would physically
go to be located
i i wouldn't be surprised if it was just
like two or three items is all but
[Music]
yeah right yes we will get you that
information
and i assume that list represents what
you would forego buying
if we didn't plus up this account
correct yes okay very good can we uh
can we move on sure so the next one
is the 8276 food emergency response
network
any questions not seeing any we can go
on
okay and then the last one in this area
is
8280 which is the biomonitoring grant
federal
all right thank you all right
thank you dr b and thank you
you're not related to harry bean are you
representative harry bean
no i'm not it's talking to him he's
related to like half the people in new
hampshire
thank you very much all right
all right the next one is one one one
one homeland security and
uh lisa did you want to bring over ian i
know
that he is fairly new but uh
we're gonna uh trisha's uh trisha is uh
available to answer some of these
questions as am i
okay great so i believe that yeah this
transfer comes from homeland security so
it comes from the department of safety
a lot of money no
yeah the next one is one one
one two which is homeland security
well this is radiological emergency
uh prevention thank you our program
so this one we've got some general funds
and we got
three times the general funds as we do
am i reading that right uh
there are also there's also agency
but yeah where's the agency income
coming from
uh i would
can you answer uh some of these
questions is this
uh through the esu
you know what we're gonna have i i don't
know that that the esu doesn't receive
that income i believe so we will have to
get back to you on that
for radiological work
so as i remember from the briefing we
did radiological surveys
routinely around the nuclear plant and
the
basically the the fallout zone of
is in a and if that's all we're doing
it just looks like a lot of money to do
just that
so i believe these are uh
there is the uh uh rep program
in protection and we just have to
understand
what um what this particular um
uh au is and i apologize for not having
that information but we will get that
for you
okay all right all right that that's
fair
yeah it's just dividing out between
what's in protection and what's in this
unit and
as you know these are brand new funds to
dphs so we're still getting our
um okay so so if we're monitoring c
c brook somebody had to have that
program before dhhs had it then
so it got transferred from somebody it
got transferred from the office of the
commissioner and i should have asked my
finance person for the office the
commissioner to be on today and i
didn't think too so that's i'm sorry
that we'll just have to follow up
no problem okay so we can go to 1113
i think yes
which is hospital preparedness and this
federal
what's the next one uh the next one is
uh 11 14 which is public health
which does have some general funds in it
but it's
sorry so you have
you have 24 people in public health
emergency preparedness
wondering if one of them moved
yeah they must have i've just not seen
any
so so if i i can jump in and probably
shelly can provide some greater clarity
on this
um the phet program um has
been uh historically based within our
infectious disease program it is moving
over into the emergency services
to our new bureau of public health
preparedness
um with that um it's a pretty robust
federal funding source and it has funded
a number of
positions throughout both the division
and historically when the esu was in the
commissioner's office
so they're spread around we are doing
some um you know consolidating right now
of trying to get all the positions in
the right place
okay so is there a match or an moe here
and if it's a match go ahead i'm sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt you
um the notice of award um states that we
have to match 10
so it's not always the same dollar
amount sir
so is there a maximum though if they
said we could do 10
up to a certain level no there's no
maximum
if there are additional questions um dr
daly is still on the call
uh this particular au has been in her uh
well if we don't if we only have a 10
percent
match here this is really is
to use miss tilly's remark this is a
really a rich source of federal funding
and i'm i'm just curious do did you have
any prioritized
needs here are you are you do you feel
like
this program is adequate 24 people to me
sounds like a lot of people
but i'm not sure what what they're doing
on a day-to-day basis
i'm going to have dr daley uh talk about
this hey you
yeah thank you so historically we have
used this funding
to increase our preparedness and there's
about 15 different capabilities that we
need to
address it includes things like making
sure that we can carry out mass
vaccination
making sure that we have laboratory
testing in place epidemiology people who
are investigating different potential
public health threats
and so we've actually used the funding
to fund very
core infrastructure for public health we
use about eight positions
um seven or eight positions are funded
in the bureau of infectious disease
control
these are nurse investigators
epidemiologists people looking at data
systems to try and identify any
potential public health threats
we also find about the same number of
positions in our laboratory
these are people who are testing for
example white powder that you
might find on an envelope those types of
events still happen following 9 11.
we also fund a number of positions in
our new bureau
which was previously the emergency
services unit these are people who are
writing
plans working with our partners to
ensure our preparedness statewide
so they're doing more than preparing
they're actually doing
things like lab work and going out into
the communities
and and checking on things
we are doing response work in addition
to the preparedness work but they have
those obligations when not responding to
making sure our plans are in place um
you know keeping those up
up to date and making that networking
with our partners which has been so
critical
even for covet 19 a lot of these staff
currently are engaged in covet 19 work
yeah so so that makes sense but um what
to what
if you have 24 authorized what is your
vacancy on that do you know that's a
trivia question
um actually currently i am i don't
believe we have
any vacancies at all among those you
know
obviously like any program you will have
periodic vacancies but i think we're
it sounds like you have clinicians in
there people who could be clinicians
well we have some public health nursing
staff and they do
our investigations talking to health
care providers and patients about their
different infectious
diseases they do outbreak response we
have you know 100 outbreaks a year
in new hampshire um and so they're doing
work that's appropriate to their
clinical training
so public health nurses tend to be rns
as well right and they have
additional training as public health
specialists
yes or on the job uh training their
nursing skills while they're there may
not be drawing blood and doing clinical
functions their nursing skills
is transferable that knowledge that they
need in order to do investigations and
interacting with the healthcare
community
uh works very well the core
the core of this fep work really
prepared us
um for our covid outbreak and our
crowbit response right now so it's
really
fundament as as dr daley said it is the
fundamental infrastructure we have
to um prepare for respond and recover
from
any um great infectious disease outbreak
okay uh very good are
okay okay that's the uh classic counting
unit in that hero and
the uh very last accounting unit for
public health is 1380 which is
prescription
drug monitoring and i believe there's a
couple of people that need to come over
he said trish could you just share with
kevin who that needs to be
yeah so i believe lindsay courtney is in
the audience right now
who is the director of the officer
professional licensure and certification
and so we've asked lindsay to join us
today um she knows the detail around
these budgets these budgets have just
been transfer
transferred over to dphs
um and so um you know as you know and as
we've talked about in our introduction
we know that you know the pdmps are
designed
to improve both patient safety and and
improve public health
with the goal of reducing overdose
deaths and hospitalizations
and within the governor's budget there's
this notion that we're going to move the
program over
to dhhs from oplc
okay and also to prevent future
addictions this is the other
process all right
and i'm not seeing general funds under
total source of funds
none none that i am aware of i just
don't know what's on this next page
there are um funds associated with
um agency income what we see on here as
well is
um some uh cost recoveries which i'm
gonna
ask our our finance people to talk a
little bit or lindsay to talk about a
little
bit and then some transfers that have
occurred
one of the reasons why the governor's
office was interested in moving this
within dhhs
is dhhs has a number of federal grants
cdc grants in which we transfer some of
that money
over to the prescription drug monitoring
program
it's obviously a good program the
objectives are really good i don't i
don't know how well it's being
implemented or executed but it's
it's the right thing to be doing so
are there any questions about this from
do we want to go to the next one then it
sounds like you're all
all keyed up to to give me a five minute
briefing on this but
but i think we're good miss tilly thank
you
this is it representative you have a
question
just a quick question so i noticed that
the other agency transfers fund
funds dropped way off in the second year
in 23.
is there a reason for that could you
stick to that or
yeah i'll take a first swing and then if
um miss courtney is here attorney
courtney's here she can fill in if i if
i get it wrong
um there are a number of these federal
funding sources and i think
it was unclear at the time of the
drafting of the budget um
if there would be rollover or what the
exact amount would be in those future
years
so we anticipate that that we will need
to go through some sort of accept and
expend process
um once the once we have a firmer idea
of what those dollars will how the how
many dollars will be available from
follow-up nope
okay so i think we can continue
unless there's absolutely something you
feel like you
need to say to us about 1380 i don't
want to
no thunder stolen we're good we think
it's a great program
we're in agreement that it should it can
uh all right so where are we
are you you're you're summing up is this
the summation of the public health
budget mrs rounds it is it is and you'll
notice that
uh general funds across all of public
health um
did decrease in uh fiscal year 22 they
and then went back up a little bit and
23.
that completes public health and so
thank you lisa trish
and shelly for being on as well as the
bureau chiefs
and i would say uh congratulations
division three you have now looked at
every single
page of the dhhs budget it's been a
great pleasure
wonderful so representative earth your
hand is up
can i ask you a general question karen
yeah of course
have you had a chance to look at the
recently passed federal bill and
anticipate what impact they might have
on
your funding in the coming years um
so i i have not um
i i don't know is the um is the document
out yet
i don't think all of the wording is out
quite yet uh
you may have seen during the
presentation i did get an email
from out i always say the acronym wrong
but
i opened it briefly there i have some
summary documents
um as some funding we're anticipating um
we have made some adjustments in the
medicaid budget there were some
adjustments made in the governor's phase
anticipating that we would get the
enhanced
fmap through december uh which i think
we talked about in the medicaid budget
um beyond that uh
i have not had a chance to really think
through what impact that might have on
the
22 budget thank you
i think the largest impact really
probably is is decisions that are not
um the department's decisions which is
the
potential uh general aid that's coming
so somewhere in the public health budget
um
we have money that we contract with the
university of new hampshire
who augment about 50
of the salaries of some of the
professors
and i had asked before we got into
public health
if you would point out to me where we
had those contracts
and i i don't i don't recall hearing
uh so i don't i i apologize i didn't
recall that as a
question that we needed to respond to so
um we will certainly get you that
information in public health
yeah i i think it's a great opportunity
for us to leverage academia
and it helps the university and it helps
us
i i just would like to understand it
better and
where it's at and what we're doing and
and why it's such a smart thing for new
hampshire to be doing
and we have we have those spread
throughout budgets um
several in dr tarala's shop um as well
as
through our preventive services block
grant and and other activity areas but
it is spread around because we do really
a good partnership representative rogers
i just want to come back to you
you started the morning with a lot of
questions about tobacco secession and
and e-cigarettes and and then and then
you were quiet on us so i'm just curious
if you want to
speak up before we come off of public
health
no i just have a concern of um if we can
possibly add some more money that the
governor didn't add and the smoking
cessation
that's all your time what dollar amount
are you thinking
um i'm not sure at this point i mean i
know that he
the agency requested 400 000 i guess so
um somewhere in any range from zero to
four hundred thousand i'm not sure at
this point
okay no no no pressure i'm
thinking that on uh on thursday we can
begin having some of those detailed kind
of questions or
conversations after representative irf
gives us
an overview of of uh this afternoon
so all right i'll try to come up with an
idea by then
yes ma'am um so that's it for the public
health thank you so much
and i think we're ready for the veterans
home
wonderful thank you very much thank you
thank you you are ready for the veterans
home let me just
remove a few people and bring some
people over
okay so so we've been talking
for two hours and it's 11
25 while you're bringing them over let's
take a
like a five minute bio break for
everyone to refill their coffee and
et cetera so we'll we'll we'll come back
and uh peggy while they're on break is
there anybody else i should bring over
from the attendees list
nope just myself sir okay you got my
presentation okay kevin
um
so it's 11 30 when when people return
if you hear me and you've returned put
please
representative bean representative
i see representative rogers
okay i think i think we can get started
uh i'm really glad that commandant is
here because she's uh
as a as a veteran she's getting my bed
ready for me
so i'm looking looking forward to being
your
your guest at some point hopefully in
three or four decades
i was going to say at least three
decades right sir yeah
i hope so um
so if mr ripple is ready uh i'm
i'm i'm ready to hear what you're doing
for our veterans these days
sure well again um for the record it's
margaret lebreck and the commandant of
the new hampshire veterans home
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to make the presentation
before you today talking about the needs
of the new hampshire veterans home
in the next two years our
budget was put together in compliance
with governor sununu's
requests and this budget has been
prepared
um with the planning assumption of
having 225 residents
in our home at that time for those of
you
inquiring minds we have 92 residents
living in our home today
we do have 16 residents approved
into the tar welch side of the house and
that is the heavy medical
side of the house as well as 21 veterans
waiting to get into our life enhancement
dementia unit i will tell you that my
admissions staff
is working on approximately 86 active
applications at this time
and through that process is when it is
determined on whether a resident would
be best met
their needs on the tar side of the house
or on the dementia
side of the house and as you can imagine
we only
would have a veteran live on the
dementia side of the house if he is
either
he or she is a danger to themselves or
um or as a wandering risk we never want
to
put our residents in an area where they
um
are confined at all um unless
it's absolutely necessary uh
don't you also though on the medical
side don't you have a really significant
percentage of them
that are also suffering to some extent
dementia or alzheimer's
i i i tell you sir probably about 85
percent
of those who live here in total have
some form
of um diagnosis whether it's parkinson's
disease
alzheimer's or dementia if it has not
progressed to the point where they
are a wandering risk we would not put
them on behind the closed doors
and allow them to you know live in an
environment that allows them
the best use of their their own time
again we would only put them on the life
enhancement dimension if they were a
wandering risk
or would benefit from that program
because the um the units are much
smaller
and is much more
i don't want to use the word quiet but
uh not a lot
more of people coming and going in the
areas
so they're less distracted with the
stranger danger
i i brought that up because it's my
perception
that the acuity of your residence is
actually
more intense than a typical county
nursing home
is that is that a bad assumption um i
believe that is a correct
assumption we have um the co-morbidities
of our residents who live here
you know they could have six different
co-morbidities whether they're living
with
dementia copd again
a resident who has parkinson's disease
in relationship to
whether it was agent orange or other um
you know they just seem to
be much more frail and again our average
age is approximately 86 years old
so again they're um the population is
how's that sir yep okay uh qualified
staffing as you can imagine
particularly in nursing um our lnas lpns
and rns
is challenging has been challenging over
the years
we know that this is not just a new
hampshire veterans home challenge this
is a challenge across the nation
for people to have direct care staff
meet the needs of our veterans who live
here so we do have many vacancies
that we will continue to recruit for and
try to retain
on those that require so that we can
require
excuse me so that we're able to provide
the care that is needed um i will tell
you currently we have
12 full-time lna positions across the
uh first second and third shift eight
part-time lna positions that we're
currently um recruiting for
uh two full-time two-part-time lpns
which is licensed practical nurses
uh we are looking for six full-time rns
which are registered nurses and two
part-time registered nurses again this
has
been the trend that we've had over the
last couple of years and in prior
bienniums
where we are looking for um health care
direct
um providing staff again
our our veterans are staying curious
about
what that does to your vacancy rate it
feels to me like you've got a 20 to 30
vacancy rate and i assume you compete
geographically with the same nursing
staff
as glencliff does um we yes glencliff
although much farther north of us it is
the 12 nursing homes that are really
around the lakes region that we
compete with whether that's saint
francis home belknap county nursing home
merrimack county nursing home is only
about eight miles down the road from us
so it's a lot of the time we do passive
hiring in other words we steal their
staff and they steal our staff
um and again that that goes in a
roundabout so the budget is projected
for 225
but with my staffing levels today we'd
be comfortable
um increasing our census to 175 or 180
and really once those vacancies get
filled we would feel comfortable
i'll try not to interrupt you i just
like i said i'm just
i'm looking forward to where my bed is
that's what i'm sure
we've got a corner office all set for
you
um of course va regulations do mandate
that qualified nursing staff be
available on a daily basis and those are
our
end positions and we do ensure that
those positions are in-house um to meet
that
regulation i know that
there could have been a question in
regards to
the footnote and house bill 2 as well as
you would see
looking at our budget um the footnote
that is
after our professional house which is
on page 188 that talks about the
organizational notes
those were also put in house bill 2. we
have had those for many many years
and that is directly related to the fact
that two of our funding sources
are um based on solely on
the census of the residents who reside
here
um again the first the federal revenue
is the per diem revenue that comes from
the va
veterans affairs that gives us 115.62
cents a day
per resident who is actually in bed at
59 at night um and i kid you not when i
tell you at 11 59 at night there was a
count that's done
and those numbers are verified with the
manchester va
and that is how we get our monthly per
diem
so representative nordgren has a
question and then
i also have a question about which
section of hb2 you're referring to
because
i thought i'd gotten to be very familiar
with hb2
and i don't i don't know which which
section or paragraph
you're referring to sure on house bill 2
number 47 which allows the new hampshire
veterans home to transfer funds within
the accounting units
if you look in the actual detail which
106 which allows me to have unfunded
position and move
funds around that's directly related to
staffing
as well as 107 but the um
the footnote is 108 that talks about
um if during the biennium projected
revenues are more
i can go before fiscal and ask for those
funds to be accepted
and it also allows if it's less that my
appropriation will not be lowered
because of those revenues not coming in
because they're directly related to the
census
and of course i can't increase the sense
if i'm not able to fill
the positions because i have to cut
positions because i don't have the
census
thank you for your patience do you have
a question
yeah um i just wanted to know if your
salaries were
large enough so you were able to compete
with the nursing homes i think that was
an issue we had
with glenn cliff and i wanted to make
sure you had enough viability in your
salary line to be able to hire people if
available
thanks thank you ma'am for that question
yes the new hampshire veterans home has
gone before governor and council
over the last couple of years and asked
for an increase or an enhancement to our
nursing
salaries in order to make us competitive
so i do appreciate that
question
[Music]
okay
so the second part of the per diem of
course is those um veterans who are 70
to 100
service connected and the new hampshire
453.84 for
a service connected veteran to live at
the home and that does pay for the total
cost
in that mou with the veterans
administration
if we are accepting the higher per diem
we are not allowed
to charge room and board to that
resident because it covers
the total cost of care um and speaking
of the
room and board is the next one the
agency income is based solely again
on resident census we we look at each
one of our residents separately
based on their
their income if their income
or excuse me if their assets are above a
certain level
they are charged a full room and board
until their assets are below
um the level that is under our
administrative rules
which allows uh once they're it's under
its 90
of their income if their assets are
above 30
000 then they are charged 320 a day
which is the average that's being
charged um throughout the lakes region
area so we try to
make sure that and quite honestly if you
take the 320
plus the per diem of 115 that is our
total cost of our care
so we feel that we shouldn't be charging
our residents any more
than what it cost us to care for them
[Music]
any questions on per diem or room and
board
and again those are laid out um through
of course we have a slide slide deck
you're going to walk us through did
mr ripple did you send something earlier
on veterans home
i only had the verbal presentation shirt
so you did not have a powerpoint
okay um the third
funding source of course is fed uh
general funds and so we would
again ask that we be allowed the
footnotes that are
after our budget
to allow us to um continue with our
census
um and increasing that census as we go
the other upcoming needs of the new
hampshire veterans home of course is new
and replacement equipments whether
that's
beds or overhead lifts
and obviously those overhead lifts are
because of the greater care needs of our
veterans
the challenges that we see ahead are
women health care
bariatric care hospice care dementia
with behavioral disturbances
and we do see an increase in our vietnam
veterans being admitted to the new
hampshire veterans home
so so it i think it's fine that you
don't have power points
i don't know how you have veterans
around you and not do powerpoint but
it's sort of an inside joke but if we
could maybe we could
visualize using the spreadsheets
so if we could go maybe share the
veterans
spreadsheet and in some of the points
that you're making may be related to an
income line or an expense line
and we could use the visual or visual
ability and our hearing ability together
absolutely um kevin are you going to
bring up the new hampshire veterans home
it's 1186 is the
professional um
[Music]
and next time uh representative i'll
make sure i have a powerpoint
presentation for you
at least one with your name on it that
way you know you can put the check in
the box
okay sorry it's taking me just a second
to find it here
so so while he's doing that i have a
trivia question for you you said
that you get a higher reimbursement rate
for people with a 70
disability i'm i'm one of those people
that have
like a 90 disability that they've
adjusted down to 70 percent
and a big part of my disability is
related to
sleep apnea would would
are there other rules that would keep me
from qualifying
in that 70 to 100 disability level
no sir um you would at any veteran who
has 70 to 100
service connected disability comes and
lives at the new hampshire veterans home
free of charge from their income and is
paid for in total
by the veterans administration um the
only thing that would keep you out is if
you were a danger to others
if you were violent um and or we were
unable to meet your
sorry one one moment here is a
it starts out on um kevin ours starts at
page 1185 halfway on the page it starts
on our custodial care
and again 11 85. yeah
about halfway down you'll see new
hampshire veterans home and that's the
veterans home custodial care 5358
is all of those positions at the new
hampshire veterans home
that are not direct care so they could
be
laundry workers environmental services
which is our housekeepers
our maintenance crew
and again that part of the budget is a
hundred percent
general funds and that's a little over
eight million
in the first biennium and eight point
three
um in 23. what's your head
count for that could you scroll down a
little bit that's 94
um full-time positions sir okay how are
you doing on vacancies
here in this in this kind of actually we
do
we do have vacancies um again hit or
miss whether there's retirees and
housekeeping and laundry in our
maintenance guys
um we we do have a hard time uh
getting people to work second and third
shift in maintenance
and housekeeping uh so those are you
know we
probably we have a 25 um turnover
in those positions it seems that we you
know we get them filled
but again um night shift is
is not for everyone so we we try hard to
as people stay on that shift if a
daytime vacancy occurs
a lot of them will apply for those and
so then we're again
filling second and third shift
[Music]
okay what do you think accounted for
your general funds jumping from 7.3
million and 20 to 8.8 and 21.
again it's those vacancies and turnover
um and
people who retire and the position gets
left open for a period of time
um in 22 and 23
is is showing the full vacancy of those
positions but in 20
you see the amount go down because the
positions were not always filled
yeah i understand so you're you're
probably going to have another
decrease because of the hiring lag
really yes yes sir it certainly is a
challenge and
dietary is another one of the positions
there where we have a you know
constantly looking for dietary
physicians um and so
again we don't spend it if we don't you
know if the position is vacant
then the money does not get spent but
again we we do ask that if
it be fully funded so that we're able to
uh recruit into those positions
right where is the money that you're
spending from that
personnel line when you go and just
contract with a maintenance company or
something
um we have um a snow plowing contract
as you see if you look over um to 103
contract for
operations services that's the contract
they do snow plowing for us
we do not contract for any maintenance
housekeeping
and or laundry at this time
they are positions funded very good
i i i don't are there any questions in
this area
for the commandant we can go on
so 5359 is the professional care this
one obviously is much more detail and
this is broken down
shows you the federal per diem um as
well as the room and boards that is
charged to our veterans
um again you will see the actual expense
in 2020 for our personal services was
11.5 million
we are asking for our positions to be
fully funded
so that we are able to recruit actively
recruit for those positions
um but again if the positions are not
filled um that money does lapse back
to general funds uh excuse me lapse back
to the fund
um as it is allocated below
um the reason again why we ask that we
are allowed the transfer between
we do have an outside contract with an
agency
temporary agency for direct care
physicians
we have not had a lot of success with
that but we have had
a couple of nurses and a couple of lnas
from that and as you can see
if you look at 101 medical payments to
providers
the 242 thousand dollars and change that
was expended in 2020
that represents a couple of rns and lnas
that helped us out
again we only spend it if we need it
and so we are able to transfer between
that line
and um our temporary uh services are
excuse me
class 10 and class 101 so that
if we're able to get a full-time person
that's always what we want to do we want
somebody with consistent care to our
veterans
um but in the knee if the need is there
and the agency has somebody
that they can offer to us we want to be
able to
um expend that out of class 101.
again that is it tell me about 0-2-1
food institutions institutional food
line
um and that is exactly what it um states
that's the um
that's our dietary budget um and for the
foods whether it's uh
uh steak or hot dogs hot dogs and beans
is a saturday favorite
uh pasta um or some other kind of uh
spaghetti on wednesdays so that is
solely
food uh institutional food line
for your nutritionists and cooks
in this they're in this their payroll is
in here
their payroll would be under class 10.
yeah so i have um two dietitians
i have a dietitian's assistant we have
somebody that's constantly monitoring
our residents to make sure that um that
they're meeting their caloric
intake um and offering uh different
protein shakes or drinks
if their weight dips below a certain
percentage
so so show us the personnel line if you
would
mr ripple class 10 sir oh the
number the number of humans oh the
number of humans is um
i'm sorry 289 uh full-time
and one unclassified and that is myself
[Music]
so again we have um currently we are
actively recruiting
for 32 vacancies in that line although
we do have
that are vacant at this time um i don't
know right off the top of my head the
ones that are um totally filled because
we always have a little bit of influx
between the two
not i'm not seeing any and then here's
where
you want to draw our attention i think
to the organization note
yes this is the footnote that i feel is
very important that the home has
so that we're able to actively recruit
um even when our census is low
um i think that we need to be able to
actively recruit and um
if based on our census our census
obviously
due to the devastation of covet 19 our
census is lower
than it would normally be we were unable
to do admissions
most of last year we are starting our
admissions
on march 30th so we're hoping to get
more veterans um in the home
but if if if we would if we were to
lose our appropriation based on the fact
that our census was down
um we would have a hard time paying
those bills okay
so i'm going to talk to the committee
members a second
uh i i i had not
um anticipated us going through the
organization notes the footnotes and
having separate votes on them to make
sure that we're okay with them
uh and and and because of that
uh i'd like to to just ask
if there is a committee member now
who has a problem with this
organizational mode
because if if we don't have if no one
has a problem with it
i'd like to just have us all assume that
this is an
acceptable organizational note and move
on
so so think about it uh representative
irf
so i don't have a problem with it but i
if i'm not mistaken it is actually one
of the
hb2 numbers i guess number 107 isn't
that what you said coming on
you said 47 what one zero seven 107
so i believe we'll be considering i mean
i agree with it but i think we'll be
considering when we go
through hb2 there's i think there are
three
uh veterans items in there number 106
number 107 and number 108 coming down is
that correct
okay so those aren't on my radar as hb2
items well you may recall just yesterday
when we were going through it
somebody brought up jumping ahead and
you said well we're just doing dhhs and
that was
the jumping head was to the veterans the
three veterans oh
that's why i don't know these hp2s
because we haven't looked at the
veterans yet
correct oh so we will have to
schedule a discussion and vote on these
all right well you can do it as you
please but i just want to point out to
them no no no no no i i once we've got a
process let's use the process i
i just thought for some reason that
that i knew all our hp twos and i'd
overlooked these
okay um all right
well uh so we will be talking about
these later
and uh getting a vote on them i'm not
seeing anyone disputing it though so it
shouldn't be
an issue um all right uh we can go on
sure so 5360 is our pharmacy services
and they are exactly
um what they proclaim to be we do have
um a
contract with consultants um that uh
provide us with pharmacists and
pharmacists
technicians as you can see that's under
for consultants and the rest is exactly
what it is it's prescription drug
expenses
we do use the mckesson which is the va's
formulary and we get um i believe a
great rate
um for our pharmaceuticals again um
as you can see in 2020 with our census
was down
we just uh spent under a little bit
under 560 000
we are asking um going forward for 800
000 to make sure that we're able to meet
the needs of the census as it gets
as it increases the consultant again the
consultant line is exactly that
what was approved through governor and
council contract
so so if you have a veteran who's living
at home
and they're receiving mail order
prescriptions from
the va pharmacy then they become a
resident
in your home um do they
do they still draw their
mail order or do you halt that somehow
and you
divert it into this program so we alert
the formulary or the va that they are
moving to the new hampshire veterans
home
so they would no longer
would be receiving it via mail they
would receive it from our pharmacy
here at the new hampshire veterans home
and we would ask for our reimbursement
through our internal process if they are
70 to 100 percent
then in that per diem rate is included
the
cost of pharmaceuticals okay
um so i'm just a little confused why the
line 100 prescription drug expenses
is so high because i'm i'm thinking
if the va is just paying for them that
that line would be near zero
i know sir um most of the veterans who
live with us
are are of different category lines and
so
only certain service-connected drugs are
covered not all of the drugs that they
have
um the service connected are are
different than 70 to 100 percent
but again um i only have a handful of
those who are 70 to 100 percent
based on my overall population okay
good explanation thank you do you want
to do you want to talk about this
organization now or have we already
talked about this
it's the exact same note that resides
under five three five nine
it just allows uh for the a total
appropriation to remain
um if the amount of reimbursements go
down based on the service connected
or the the veterans who are not service
connected i would say
[Music]
sure the next one is 8147 which is
workers compensation
which we do not have a whole lot of
control over as you can imagine
um and so those numbers are based on um
what we feel has happened in the past
and so we're just rolling those forwards
pretty flat
numbers right
uh the next is um 6162
unemployment compensation again a very
small
lines and those are 100 general funds
[Music]
a little over 18 thousand
and that takes us to the end of the new
hampshire veterans home and as you can
see
we have um 383 full-time
um equivalents as one unclassified and
that's exactly what we've asked for
going forward
all right so let me let me ask you a
question
and and and and tell you in advance
i really just want a yes or no answer
not not a not a long answer just a yes
or no
um we had a number
of of deaths due to covid in the
have have you and your staff completed
an internal review and come to identity
identify the causes
that may have contributed or the
potential contributing causes
and have you taken the remediation steps
necessary to deal with those causes
yes yes do you need
is there any additional program
equipment
supply that that you would need
to keep your remediation efforts in
place
i feel that we've um that is in our
budget for 22 and 23 go and we're in
good shape going forward
[Music]
all right so representative weiler you
thank you mr chairman do you have any
any large debts
of fuel and utilities seen in the past
no sir we're totally paid up on all of
our bills and our accounts payable lines
any other questions here
okay so um
so that's that's really it commandant i
oh i do have another trivia question for
you
um okay about
six months or so ago uh i had
a roundabout uh complaint forwarded to
me by one of your
residents that originated with one of
your residents
and it was related to the idea that
because of the way that wi-fi was
provided inside the building
that all of the residents who had
internet accounts needed to go directly
to their own commercial providers of the
internet
and that created a lot of contention
and network problems for them
there was some discussion with doit
of expanding the government side
of the wi-fi and segregate segmenting it
so that the residents
could use a single point of access
instead of having to go
for their own commercial version
i i understand that a decision was made
to require the residents to to continue
getting their own
commercial carrier for internet service
instead of expanding the state network
do you do you remember this do you have
anything
i do sir and um after you had reached
out to me i reached out to doit
and asked them to explain to me in
detail exactly what they were offering
because we had had such a hard time at
the home even getting a commercial
provider to come in
with the concrete walls
as the home has been built and the
different dark spots that we have around
the building
and i
apologize i don't remember their exact
response
but someone had reached out and said
that there was a cost
quite a large cost to this but that that
cost could be
then
diverted off to our residents which i
must tell you that i'm taking 90 percent
of their income just for them to live
here so i
um had a hard time um
going forward with a cost that i didn't
know how much more it was going to cost
them
uh where atlantic broadband was the only
people who had bid
on when we went out to bid i'm asking
for
a company to come in and provide um
computer services for our residents i
will tell you
that we provide basic services
throughout the home basic tv
um but the if they wanted an additional
or a computer
with a phone attached to it that they
had to do that on their own
because of the um the cost and the
um i i again
um i don't know the exact amount that
doit was talking about
but um it didn't sound like a small
amount
and sir small amount of work that needed
to be done in order to
increase the bandwidth here at the home
and to have that because again
if the residents are by the library or
um by the town hall
they are able to access the wi-fi that
is available to them free of charge
bounce that throughout the home because
we do have
our medical carts that need to be on a
segregated
due to hipaa guidance so we need to make
sure that that
it absolutely has to be locked down we
can't have any hipaa or phi
issues going on our med carts are on
wi-fi and so
um it was very concerning that we would
have two um potential
uh signals being um thrown out through
the home
and that our med carts would pick up on
that
and be um have an issue with the
transmission of the medical record
so let me translate that into what's
important to me that i think
i heard you say that if the
resident is able to move to known
locations
in the health center that they can get
good
strong internet access at no cost to
them
that is correct and we have a computer
room called the ben pen excuse me
um what did we call it i'm sorry i've
lost my mind um we've got
three free computers that sit in a room
that they can go
and they can access whether they're
skyping with their family their loved
ones
they have computer access we just do not
provide
access computer access in their
individual rooms
um if they're over by the library the
main street area they're able to um
access
the internet free the wi-fi is there
free we are not
able to blast it across the entire house
i get it so so i'm just curious with the
lockdown
you don't call it lockdown but with the
segregated
alzheimer dementia unit where they are
kept securely because there are escape
risks
are they able to go to the portion of
your building where they
need internet access or or maybe the
real answer there is
there they have a mental condition that
really makes it so they're not
internet seeking people to begin with
that is correct but if there's a family
member who wants to reach out to one of
our veterans
in that area they're able to take a
secure laptop or
tablet over there and interact so and
and set it up so that that resident
is able to communicate to their loved
ones from
their unit where they're safe and secure
so it sounds to me from what you've said
that you share
with that we share a common concern that
particularly with covet and
the inability of families to come in
that this
skyping and zooming is vastly more
important than it was
over a year ago and absolutely we have
about 15
currently laptops pads tablets
and our recreational staff who have
access to
wi-fi and they're able to get around to
the residents whose family and
again they set up specific times um
that they're either phone calls again
skyping face timing
um so that these uh families and their
loved ones are able to communicate
as well as window visits as you know
we have areas around the building that
is clear glass
some of our our family members have said
you know it's too hard to come in
and have a mask on and be six feet away
i can't hear him he can't hear me
i would rather do a window visit and so
we set them up with
a lawn chair and or a comfortable chair
on the outside of a glass window
and their loved ones on the inside and
they're on cell phones talking to each
other
because they can hear each other better
i'd like to change
uh the topic of the conversation
about two and that's all those are all
great answers i just i just wanted to
follow up with you
and see if you needed more money for
repeaters internet repeaters and it
doesn't sound like you do
um but the other ques question is
two years ago or so maybe it's been
three and time flies but
uh i came out and did a site visit with
you i don't know if you remember to look
at whether or not
the va manchester or the va in vermont
would provide you with telemedicine
support
and if that telemedicine support in
theory if it was going to be able to
help you reduce your personnel
requirements
it has has there been telemedicine put
into place
and what affect if any has it had on
your personnel needs
um actually we had some of our residents
as you know who um still travel down so
we had to have to have to do
transportation down to the va
or to a cboc that they're receiving
mental health
so we have had mental health come in the
va
issued us a specific laptop that they
felt
met their guidelines to the va needs
in order for one of their providers to
provide telehealth medicine to our
veterans
and so we started that probably uh the
end of august last year
and um from the amount that or the
conversations i've had
with my staff it seems to be going quite
well some of our residents are okay with
that others
don't care for it so um we work around
what our residents feel comfortable
doing
okay so it sounds like it's relieved a
little bit of pressure
on the fact that you have vacancies but
you're not really
ready to get rid of any permanent
positions because of it
no because unfortunately we have plenty
of our residents who still need to go to
outside providers for different things
and so i get it
so um are there any questions from any
i i really appreciate um you coming in
and talking with us
and uh and frankly just having you talk
directly to the spreadsheet
i think uh was very efficient
and for me it was effective so so
i i wouldn't say that you should be
concerned you didn't have any powerpoint
and just
other than i've never seen a military
briefing
without one so i didn't know it was
possible but uh
all right i i don't have any further
questions
um do you does anyone in the committee i
i'm not seeing any so i i think you can
go have a great day
thank you sir thank you um for allowing
me to present
before you and i hope you all have a
great day
so so mr ripple um
i think we're getting close to a
lunchtime
um i think when we come back from lunch
i want us to go look at section 22 of
hba and see if we can approve it
then we'll have uh representative walner
kind of introduce us to the topic of
section 39 the forensic mental health
hospital
we'll go uh talk about how we might do a
quick sort
on on some of the accounts so we
have a smaller target of mass
and then hb1 representative irf will
talk about that and introduces so i
still think we have a pretty full
and productive afternoon
uh representative wallner uh let's go
with nordgren first because she raised
her hand first
representative nordgren thank you mr
chair um
and at lunch time i will send the email
out
about the division three comments we
have on various
budgets we think we could pass okay
that'd be great and then we'll just
we'll try to talk about them then we'll
look at your email yeah thank you it's
very helpful
appreciate it uh representative
um this is i just have a request of
kevin
so kevin when we talk about um
section 39 could you just have
um the language from the
previous budget available so that we can
see
the language that was in um house bill i
guess it was in house before
yeah sure i can bring that up okay and i
also i
i guess i could just forward it to
everyone but um senate bill 156
okay okay great thank you
is that from a prior year senate bill
no it's it's there now they've had a
hearing on it
thank you um
all right so mr ripple i'm ready to go
to
uh recess do you have anything for us
before we we break for lunch
i do not if you wouldn't mind putting up
a sign
that we'll come back at one and i i
don't know
i don't think we need to have the
recording on while we're at lunch i
don't know
okay good and uh and we're recording so
so division three is coming out of its
uh it's it's lunch break
um when we broke we said that we would
come back and we would discuss
uh start by discussing section 22
of house bill 2.
if you have the march madness calendar
there's the link there to the official
um website where
the the language should be so
let's let's everyone get on
i do have section 22 pulled up here so i
can share my screen if that doesn't work
well that that's probably helpful i just
uh
okay i found it
well it's better to share it anyways so
that we know that we're looking at the
same thing
my notes on this
um
we were thinking instead of a repeal
maybe suspended
and we heard from ms altman who said
that she thought that repeal was
still the right way to go um there was
some question
of whether or not the congregate housing
is the main issue and if it should be
separated from the
grandfather or the grandparent foster
program
so um i think if i remember right
representative walner you you had
the concern about whether this should be
a suspension instead of a repeal
am i remembering that right uh yes
mainly because they they were in the
so did ms altman's uh
remarks placate you any or or
because she's still advocating for
repeal
i you know what i it doesn't really
matter i
i think that this is a very popular
program with it with
some people in the senate so we'll
so um so we're repealing
is i'd like to hear a motion
is there a motion to accept
i would make a motion to appeal
so say say your motion again i i missed
it
can't turn that off i'm sorry um i would
move that we
repeat we accept house bill 2
number 22 which is repealing
several rsas i'm going to read them to
you so i understand that motion is there
representative weiler seconds
go ahead your rep you recognize
representative wohler
okay i am going to uh vote no
okay because you you think this should
be a suspension instead of a repeat i
think
just be a suspension
is there any is there any other
discussion
i'm not seeing any uh i think the clerk
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walner no
representative no
representative rogers no
representative edwards uh
okay all right
so uh i i so we'll be
going forward with a repeal and then
representative walnut i
i know you have friends in the senate
maybe uh maybe we'll see this again
you might okay so
um representative
or excuse me mr ripple did you
slide down to section 39 or
or really whatever representative
wallner wants to do now she has the
floor
so section 39 is the uh section
uh that pertains to the uh
psychiatric forensic unit so
kevin maybe we could
so are people feeling familiar with what
was in house bill 2.
it really was um 17.25
million dollars to construct a
60-bed forensic hospital
and it suggests it doesn't suggest it
directs that the department
would use federal funding
if if it's available yes
to pay for it and if it's not then the
17.250 would be bonded
um so i was kind of concerned about that
because i wondered how
how you did that outside the capital
budget and i had concerns about the
capital budget so i did it
over the weekend just did a little
research about what kinds of bills have
we had before
um we've had a number of bills around
this
most of them set up study committees and
oversight committees but there is right
now
a bill in the senate it's senate bill
and it they are re it's the motion will
be to re-refer it
um in the senate
so they're obviously holding it in the
senate
um what this bill does is basically and
i'll show you what
what was in the um in house bill
4 from this period
it basically is the sum of 8.75
million it's a 25-bed psychiatric
facility it cannot be
contracted out to a private provider
let's see i can't remember exactly the
management of the secure psychiatric
facility shall be
the responsibility of the department of
health and human services
and the department may may contract with
a private psychiatric service
provider but shall not enter into a
contract
for the construction or operation of the
facility with a private
for-profit prison construction or
management company
so that's what the senate bill says
and now kevin can we go to show what was
in-house before
when you're ready for a question i think
representative erp has his hands up
oh okay i'm fine if a question fine
thank you representative walnut um maybe
i'm misreading this but
when i read this hb2 section three
it sounds about they're asking for
another 17 million quarter on top of
what as i recall was in the original
hp right four so they're looking at like
million dollars total so i have that
right
i'm not really sure but i would like to
look at i'm not really sure if they're
adding it on
it see they have they already have the
authority
right they already have the authority
to get 8.75
million to build a 25 unit
uh a 25 bed hospital and that
that's sp 60 50 156 though right didn't
we didn't
the our last hb4 include a 60-bed
unit with more money like 17 million
dollars
no uh can we go to the house before
sorry
yeah okay here's house bill for this is
what we did
two years ago it's
8.75 and it is a 25 bed
hospital and this they have
they did not spend down is that right
kevin they didn't spin this down
that's my understanding and that's why
in the current
trailer bill it starts with the
department shall proceed with the
construction of a 60 bed facility
utilizing funds appropriated in the
fiscal year ending june 30th 2021. so i
believe that references the original
8.75 million
right so they already have the authority
for the
for the 8.75
so this it seems to me
like we could almost take
out what's in here and just
they already have the authority for the
8.75
um and they can proceed with that gives
them the
right to proceed with the 25 bed
hospital
so they but they've increased it to a 60
bed hospital
they had well they increased it
in house bill 2 they they requested an
increase 260.
okay so they're authorized for 25 beds
and they have some
money authorized and that money
was authorized is is non-lapsing it's
still good even if it goes into the next
it says here the sum appropriated shall
be non-lapsing provided that any
unexpected amount of
construction shall lapse to the general
fund so
so what is it is is it a correct
understanding then that what they're
doing is
increasing the bed count from 25 to 60
increasing the costs associated with it
and
creating an avenue to bonding to get the
extra money
if we don't appropriate it is that is
that a correct understanding
that sounds yes what that's what it
looks like house bill 2 was doing
yeah so that's my understanding too i i
just would note that karen does over
hand raised
yeah i was about to go to representative
rounds next
okay
uh thank you uh kevin if you don't mind
just bringing over joe christie as well
because there may be
some questions that are a little more
in-depth that he might be able to answer
but just to give a little bit more
history the appropriation
that was in the final house bill 4 was
for a 25 bed unit and the amount
appropriated was only half the amount
that was needed to construct that 25 bed
unit
the idea being that we would only need
half the funds
last biennium to start the construction
and additional funds would be
appropriated
in 2223 the
original uh proposal made by the
department
and the governor that were in the house
bill 2 has introduced in 2021
was a 60 bed unit that i believe was
closer to that 40 million
number that was mentioned earlier
so so if you want to hand it off to mr
christie that's
that's fine with me we're just talking
joe do you have anything else you would
you would add as background or current
information
um i don't i apologize i i
was being brought over when uh when you
were speaking so i didn't quite hear
everything that you had just said karen
but
um but in general it
uh the initial construction for a 25 bed
facility was estimated to be around
16.5 million half of which was
appropriated last biennium
um and as karen mentioned that the at
the end of her
point there uh the departments in the
so uh representative weiler your hand
was up
i thank you mr chair now a lot of what
we've been looking at lately in viewing
is how much
people are in emergency departments
because it is
for them and all this kind of delay and
all that we get
emails as well about that so is this
60 versus 25 because of all this
pressure it seems like we
have an increase in in mental health
problems is that true
no
um so again this is uh joe cruz the cfo
of new hampshire hospital
so uh the increase to 60 beds is not
necessarily a reflection of the
emergency boarding room crisis that's
that's grown over the pandemic
um i this facility is really targeted
more
at the forensic patient population
who you know many of which are currently
there there could there would be some
patients at new hampshire hospital that
would be appropriate for this facility
and so that
that regard it would free up some
capacity for individuals in emergency
rooms but that's not necessarily the
primary intent here it's more about
those individuals
or currently has a department of
corrections um but
but maybe don't have any sort of
commitment per se so i believe that's
that's really where this this came from
i i joined the team uh
right around committee a conference when
this was being discussed
[Music]
yes sir uh if these people move from the
um prison where they house now
does that mean that we'll have lower
i don't know that we can speak for
corrections i i don't
i don't know the definite answer to that
but the
i don't know how many people they have
in their um
in their facility but they would no
longer be there
thank you representative norgren
thank you mr chair um
maybe karen can follow up with us
on how many they have over at the
concord
uh prison that would be helpful the
other thing i would bring up again
i think we've discussed is that none of
this seems to be going through the
capital budget
and the public works committee
and the bonding outside of house bill 2
doesn't sound very reasonable anyway
just a comment and a question
thank you so my understanding from the
governor's office is that
um and i i think i've provided this
information
but that the the intent of the federal
funds would be the federal stimulus
funds in the bill that just passed um at
the federal level
we don't have any other department funds
federally that we could use for this
purpose
most of our grants do not allow us to
build infrastructure we can
often repair things and and that type of
thing but we cannot build infrastructure
um the as far as the bonding goes my
understanding is that
the intent was that if the federal
stimulus dollars were not available
that in a later phase of the budget uh
when we knew for sure that they were not
available we would work
in a likelihood with the senate at this
point to try to work that into the
i think and i was just looking to see if
i had it um
i was wondering how it was what i was
sitting here wondering was how many
um people there are at the prison now
that would transfer
over to this type of a facility
and i believe the senate did get some
testimony around that or at least
um some information about that
so i would like i think i think the
department of corrections
could provide that for us and i someone
sent me an email about it and i'm just
so if i could append to your question
the extended part of the question which
is
we we're not seeing any prospective head
count
for how many people need to be needed
to staff a 60-bed forensic hospital and
and it could be quite significant um
and so we ought to be looking at the
manpower and personnel costs
so that go ahead sorry we're staffing
this hospital
you know with we build it we need to
operate it so
i'm just curious what the head count
would be to demand this hospital and and
to represent walnuts question what
number of them are being transferred
from the prison system because these are
still
from these are criminal mentally ill
people right
no not always not always sometimes
they're they're held because they're um
not guilty for reason of insanity or
unfit to stand trial
um and so therefore have not been
convicted
um i i
think that we have done the analysis on
what a staffing model might look like
um of course the staff wouldn't come
into play until
uh the 2425 biennium
but i think we could um provide you with
what
what we have estimated the staffing
model to look like it's a little
early to know for sure until we know
exactly what the building will look like
um so the design phase is done but we
can give you an estimate so
representative wilder question uh
we keep seeing the statistics of people
waiting in
emergency rooms what are we doing about
it and this and that
we passed this two years ago and
nothing's happened
so we now we see an opportunity i think
in the next month or two
to find out we've got money coming from
the feds
to help build this and i think the best
thing we can do right now
is pass it and see what the uh
we've got two more months before we see
what's going to
happen in the future and
already been delayed in my mind two two
years so
i think i would just assume rather than
delay
uh pass this out and send it along as it
comes to us
thank you so so i have a question about
what you just said and then
has the department clearly stated
because i don't recall it
have they clearly stated that this
60-bed facility
will directly influence the reduction
of the warehousing of mentally ill
patients in emergency rooms
no no so so i i'll let joe add he does
have his hand raised too so
i'll speak first and then would ask to
let joe speak
so when we testified back when it was a
60-bed facility
yes it would most certainly free up beds
at new hampshire hospital
it if it was a 25 bed facility i believe
it only replaces the
secure psychiatric unit at the prison so
maybe that's the answer for the number
of beds but we'll get you that as well
um but it would absolutely free up beds
at new hampshire hospital
joe and therefore get the warehousing uh
emergency rooms down it it would
open up beds at new hampshire hospital
to allow more input
more people from the hospital yes okay
and then joe did you did you want to
you raised your hand right as she was
speaking or you got a joint answer
i i just wanted to confirm what she said
so at the
60 bed level um that would be where new
hampshire hospital would be able to free
up some additional census
the facility at a 25 bed unit likely
would not
impact emergency room boarding it would
solve more of
an issue where we have civilly committed
or not guilty by reason of insanity
individuals housed in a department
corrections facility
thank you representative walner um i
just
karen i just wondered if we had had do
we have
any guidance from the federal government
as to whether they will
in this new round of funding allow
us to do capital projects
i have not um had an opportunity to read
the summaries on on that on those funds
i
i've only focused on the the stuff
that's been specific to hhs so far
and uh mr chair i i was just wondering
if you might want to
ask if there's anyone in the audience
who has
information around this i know that two
years ago when we um
when we looked at this there were
people who had taken a lot a long look
at this kind of
um of a forensic hospital
and had information about it
okay we could we can do that um
representative rogers has her hand up
let's let's address her
first and then we could go to the
audience
mr chairman i'm just concerned a lot of
the questions we're asking today
for the same questions we were asking
two years ago and we're not getting
answers still
but one thing that concerns me and maybe
miss rounds can answer this
two years ago we asked um if my city
concord had ever been approached
about this facility and about what it
would mean
since this is going to be put in on the
state hospital grounds
which is located between two schools the
junior high school
and the senior high school and next to a
daycare center in the city
and we asked if they'd done anything by
contacting the city and asking
for their input in it and we were told
they had and then when i talked to the
mayor he'd never heard of it
i'm going to ask again hope for an
honest answer this time
has the city been involved in any of the
planning if any has been done
karen so if i could just uh
okay so you use the word honest there i
think what we're looking for
is is a correct answer i don't think we
wanna
i am not aware of what conversations
have been happening joe can you
he's saying yes he's aware so i'll let
joe jump in there sure
um we actually in a the most recent uh
design meeting we had with our
colleagues down at public works that was
one of the first things that we talked
about was
needing to reach out and engage with the
city of concord
around this i mean i believe and i
please don't take me as the expert on
this but i believe um
any major project that happens in the
state office complex
um i believe it actually has to be
coordinated with
uh the city of concord so but that is
certainly
our intention so you you intend to talk
to them but you haven't talked to them
yet
um the design uh engineers down at
public works may have
um i'm i'm more on the finance side of
this project so i don't wanna
i don't want to give you a false answer
but
we just discussed that i'm just
concerned it's been an additional two
years
and the city hasn't been involved in any
of this and it does have an impact i
know that the state quite often doesn't
think it does impact our city but it
does
and i'm concerned that in two years time
there's not been contact and they
haven't been intimately involved
with a 60-bed unit of um
forensic mentally ill people
and people coming in i understand the
need for it but i also represent the
city of concord
where we have individuals and i'm very
concerned that in two years time mr
chairman
the department hasn't found the need to
do anything but
think about reaching out so that's one
thing that concerns me but it also
concerns me
that a lot of the questions were asking
me here today were questions we asked
two years ago
and it started out as a 25 bed unit and
now it's a 60 bed unit
so um i have great concerns about this
project
it doesn't two years ago it wasn't well
planned out and it doesn't seem
very well planned out now when they've
had two years to work
on design and everything else and it
doesn't seem much has been done frankly
okay so so thank you for those comments
i
just to remind the committee today was
scheduled to make sure that we
we talked through uh this section and we
weren't going to vote on it until
thursday
um in case there's follow-up issues and
the like
uh i i would i would like to share a
con a part of a conversation i i that
representative wallner and i had
this weekend and representative walner
if i if i misremember any of this
please correct me
but i i think when we talked about this
i
said that my my concerns uh around this
is that this really feels like it needs
to um
go through the legislative process and
have a full committee
looking at it and a and a fiscal note
attached to it
and that and that we were we were
doing a capital project in an hb2
and that and and i'm the new guy so i
don't know if that's
a good thing to do or a bad thing but it
feels to me like we have
capital budgets for a reason
and uh and this is looks like it may be
circumventing that um so what
what what i think i laid out to
representative wallner was the
possibility
of taking this out of hb2
from the house version of it letting the
senate
work on their bill
but meanwhile in early april our
committee
could have more of a of a hearing
where we invite people in so we can
so we can behave more like a committee a
policy committee than just
a finance committee so so that that was
sort of one idea that got floated that's
very different than what you said
earlier representative weiler and i want
to respect that
and represent nordgren you don't have to
take your hand down i
i wasn't going to talk forever and you
you're on mute though
you probably said everything i was
already thinking i was
thinking if nothing else we could remove
this from
our version of house bill 2 and then
send it to the senate and hopefully we'd
have more information
on how to proceed but i think you're on
the right track
thanks all right representative wallner
since i was signing our conversation was
i
i missed something
no i think that that pretty much summed
it up i
i was excited when i saw that the senate
had
was i did have a bill and that the bill
actually
um matched sort of what was in
what was in the budget from la from two
years ago
but they have re-referred it they're
they're holding on to it
so i there's obviously going to be a
time when the senate and the house are
going to be able to talk about this
so possibly holding an information
session
later on in april when we have more time
i think that i think there's merit to
that
representative and your hand was up and
down down did you do you have another
comment
no representative weiler since what i
said kind of contradicts what
what you were recommending i what are
probably that'll work the way you the
way you propose and i think that
i think um representative walner
uh considers it the same and i we've got
enough time
before we have a deadline i just wanted
to move it along because i thought
but your plan would move it along one
way or the other so i would
go with that okay
okay so so what i what i think
we'll do on thursday and and this will
give people a chance to think about it
and i think we'll probably have a motion
to vote to remove section 39 of our
version of house bill 2
with the idea that we would uh begin
scheduling a more of a policy committee
uh review of this um
in early april so that our committee can
get
smarter about this and get ready to give
some of that information to the senate
if they don't already have it
with their hearings on sb 156
or alternatively make us smarter so
we're prepared for
that that's what i think we might vote
on on monday
are there are there any comments mr
ripple what what what
do you you're being quiet as you
normally do in this phase of the
conversation but i'm curious what you're
thinking
no i think that's fine um i would just
know
two things one you do have one hand up
in the audience if you if you want to
hear from that person
and another if you vote to uh remove it
i don't think it would just be a vote to
remove as you've been voting to
approve so far you would actually need
an amendment that removes that section
but we can have that all right
so so let's go to represent a weiler and
then and don't let me forget we got a
took your hand down i would suggest that
the
motion or the amendment to remove it is
for further discussion
uh you know so that it's obvious we
haven't
killed it we're just removing it for
further discussion that's all
thank you all right
you want to bring in whoever our guest
is that wants to speak on this
sure
good afternoon mr chair uh mike skivy
from the disability rights center
um i just wanted to make a couple of
quick comments um
i think um the 25 bed census amount
made a lot of sense when it was in the
last budget or should i say the current
budget
because that basically covers the
civilly committed population that has
now been transferred to
the secure psychiatric unit i think
there's pretty general
consensus that that census amount would
take care of
basically removing people from the
prison who have not been sentenced
um but are more properly in a more
civilly um appropriate therapeutic
environment i think that if you do go
up to 60 then you are definitely
creating a net increase in your
hospital capacity and i think there's
pretty good evidence that you don't
have a problem of bed capacity you have
a problem of
of using your bed capacity basically to
house people who are ready for discharge
i think that you've probably already
heard from a number of people that
you've got about half your beds at new
hampshire hospital are being held by
people who are ready for
for discharge and i think that that's a
problem that you're not going to build
your
your way out of here you need to deal
with that problem with
a much less expensive enhancement to the
mental health system which is to create
discharge
destinations for those people and to
create supports in the community so that
they don't need to come back
pretty quickly after they were
discharged
may i ask you a question sir certainly
um do you think your organization or you
have had an
opportunity to fully provide testimony
to
a policy committee on this topic
it's never been before a policy
committee but i certainly
spoke at some length on a couple of
different occasions
before division three and the full house
finance committee
when the current budget was being
prepared and it was after
that sort of back and forth that the
uh that the current provision was
adopted which provided for 25 beds which
basically takes care of the
the actual problem which is that you've
got people at the secure psychiatric
unit that shouldn't be
in that environment but i'd be happy to
go over that
those issues again i'm basically my
testimony would reference
independent assessments of the problem
in new hampshire
one of which was a report in 2017 that
was commissioned by the department
itself
and another is the the periodic reports
of the expert reviewer who analyzes
whether the state is in compliance with
okay so i do have one other question for
you
i i understand your point about
going from 25 to 60 with that 35
bed extra capacity it would probably
still get filled up
because we don't have the
community-based alternatives to
discharge
people into but but wouldn't that 35
also though absorb more people and get
more people out of the emergency room
warehousing
i i think that the dynamic is one that
we've seen repeatedly
um which is that um
when you take out um people from the
hospital it's basically the same thing
as adding a bed right and so we've done
that before we've
we've created transitional housing and
transferred a couple of dozen people at
times
out of new hampshire hospital but that
but those beds don't remain in play they
basically
get filled up again by people who are
not ready for discharge
but are put i'm sorry that are not that
are ready for discharge but don't have a
place to go and and we've seen it most
recently with the creation of the 16
transitional housing unit
uh beds um on the campus at the old
philbrick center
i mean i think probably the most helpful
analogy is a simple one but i think it
applies
is that you know if if you have you know
a bathtub of a particular capacity
that keeps overflowing because your
drain is running fast
is running more slowly than your faucet
is
then you can take a few buckets of water
out of that bathtub and it'll stop
overflowing but only
only for a brief period of time before
you know the
the inherent problem with your system
which is that the drain isn't running
fast enough
to keep up with the faucet is going to
overcome the capacity again and the same
thing would happen
if you added a net of 35 beds to
new hampshire hospital if you don't have
places to discharge people
then you're going to fill up those beds
again and you're still going to have
this problem
i mean we've we've had a net increase in
beds over the last couple of years in
new hampshire
and we've got a larger boarding
population today than we did
you know 12 months ago and maybe two
years ago i i'm not exactly sure what
the count is compared to 24 months ago
but we've definitely seen
those two those two
things running in opposite directions in
recent months
and so i think that's because of what i
said which is that your problem
is that you you're not discharging
people as quickly as you're admitting
them
and so you've got people backed up at
the front door
okay well thank you uh
representative erf do you have a
question for mr skibby or or just
in general no no i do have a question
for him yes
so it sounds like you're saying the
problem can't be
solved um so what is the solution
because that as
i was listening to you two years ago
that's why i recall the whole
conversation about transitional housing
and as you say
it's some of it has been built um
but if that hasn't helped solve the
problem what is the solution
well transitional housing if it's used
truly to transition
that is somebody is there very briefly
before they're
moved into a more permanent
living situation in the community then
transitional housing can be part of the
solution
but the real solution is that you get
people out into the community
to permanent places to live and you keep
them stable
in those permanent places so they don't
show up at the front door again
i certainly didn't mean to say that the
problem can't be solved the problem can
be solved by coming into compliance with
the mental health agreement
that is by providing the community
supports that the state agreed to
provide
because we know that when you do that
people don't show up at your front door
again
and also by providing other supported
housing
that keeps people permanently and more
stably living in the community
you can you can keep building beds and
eventually you'll have
every mental health patient um in an
inpatient facility and you'll stop
you know having them in the middle in
the emergency rooms but you're going to
be talking about a lot more than 35 beds
before you solve it that way the way you
need to solve it is that you need to
have your throughput working that is you
have
all of your beds filled with people who
need an inpatient level of care
not have half of them filled with people
who are basically living there
are there other questions from mr skibby
okay i'm i'm not i'm not seeing any
um i i have a question for you mr ripple
and maybe for uh chairman weiler too
do do we do we think we have
finance committee obligations the whole
committee
on april 5th or 6th that's monday or
tuesday before our three-day
i'm not aware of any just take a quick
look at the calendar here
i'm wondering if we should block or or
if division three should anticipate that
monday or tuesday the fifth or sixth if
if those are full finance days or if we
could
maybe hold a public hearing on
on this hp i think i i doubt you would
have i doubt full finance would have
anything going on on those days since
it's
do you agree there chairman weiler
yes i think we could we could have a
hearing or maybe even before the full
committee
you want the full finance committee
maybe on this well
if it worked best for the schedule
okay so so um just i'm just looking for
a sense of uh
division three is the monday or the
tuesday
the fifth or the sixth better we could
go ahead and try to start a scheduling
to
yes representative i i was just
gonna check with um representative
weiler
what day will you be doing the briefing
i haven't really scheduled that yet i
the only thing that bothers me about
doing it on that monday or tuesday
when on wednesday you're going to have
the budget on the floor
right and there's a lot of preparation
work
people have to do to get to get ready
for that i just
i mean those seem like to me like dave
you might have caucuses
you might be briefing your caucus we'd
be briefing hours i just
so let's let's jump ahead and assume
you're absolutely
correct should it then seems like we
should go ahead
and wait until the 12th or 13th that
monday or tuesday
to get it past our house sessions
so so of those days the 12th or the 13th
monday or tuesday is there a sense of
what the division would prefer i
i don't i don't care so if anyone has a
strong
you know don't do it on this day this is
a good time to speak up
well i was i was kind of waiting for the
divisions to finish
before i i tried to schedule the full
committee and i was hoping that would
happen
you know within the week i could
possibly have it
like the end of march or even the first
of
april yes yes sir i i think if we move
what we're talking about the review of
this house bill
yes section 39 to the 12th of the 13th
to april though
we're just clearing the deck for you to
pick when you need to pick
and then we're also giving room for
representative walner's concept that
we've got a lot of homework to get ready
to talk to the full house
so correct yeah okay
so i'm not hearing anyone complain about
either the 12th
or the 13th may i
offer a piece of information yes ma'am i
do believe that the senate finance is
going to start meeting on the 12th
i don't believe that they're likely to
meet until the afternoon though
so maybe in the morning of the 12th
might be
an option i think the house finance
presents to
senate finance on the 12th potentially
but not till the afternoon
okay whatever we find on this house bill
item i i i don't know how it works i
think we'll
be informally communicating to the
senate in any case but
or through kevin except kevin can't be
in two places at once maybe that's what
you're saying
uh mr ripple are you do you know what
you're doing on the 12th
i'm taking a look at the senate calendar
now um
so no off the top of my head i'm not
sure okay
so if you would take a note to maybe
pencil us
in for monday the 12th in the morning on
the idea that the senate finance people
won't start till the afternoon
then we can have a morning hearing on
section 39.
okay
all right and then i think we would like
to on thursday
have a vote of division three
on an amendment to strip section 39
out of house bill 2.
do i need to give you something in
writing for that
no you don't we can just have it drafted
to remove that section
okay so representative wallner since
this was your topic today
are you satisfied with where we're at
yes i i like the idea of us having a a
more open discussion where public can
come in where
other people can come in and talk to us
about this i think it's a good i think
it's good
okay good good good good
uh with that representative earth
why don't you have us why don't you
educate us
tell us what you've done with house bill
does anyone need a break a few minutes
break before we get into that
i i think i actually could take a minute
or two
so so while you and mr ripple get
ready um i'm going to step away for a
few moments
okay
go go ahead uh representative weiler
what what
they they would like me to appear at
edna at three o'clock i'm still not sure
for what
but
step away a few minutes before yes sir i
think we're gonna be down before three
so kevin if you could bring up the draft
funding analysis budget that's dated
today
and everybody should have a copy of it
that i sent out
can you all see that okay it seems kind
but my original is very clear yeah
unfortunately i'm not sure if there's
anything i can do anything about that
because it does look clear on my screen
okay can you maybe blow it up a little
bit then
i might have a little there you go
oh it's better that's better kevin okay
now you don't have to go too far yeah
most of them even talking about kevin is
at the top
okay so so i'm back
uh harry's not here
representative nordgren's not here
there's there's there's representative
bean so we found a bean in
new hampshire that's not related to you
harry
i wouldn't bet on that yet
okay i think we should wait for
representative nordgren before
problem
i do i can't read it but i can see it
john bean or jim bean or john bean
move it to your left a little there you
go
from exeter see how thick that is
that's why it takes me a while to figure
out if she's actually in there but she's
probably married to
as probably her married name as a guest
have you have you sent out uh keith have
you sent out
the uh the line by line that you used to
build this i have kind of yeah
intentionally but i did send it out when
i meant to send this out so they have
both
[Music]
so so mr ripple while we're waiting for
representative nordgren
i've got a question for you okay
okay so this document that um
representative erf has created to
explain to us what he's done
is is really the summary of a tremendous
amount of line by line work that he's
done
that line by line work that he's done is
kind of in a process document
it's not a final document to what extent
should we use are we obligated or
or is it appropriate for us to share
publicly
that line by line that we know isn't the
final document it's just a way for us to
work and communicate
if it's a proposal that you and
representative europe are willing to
share there's
i don't think there's any harm in
sharing it i i don't really care to
because i know it's going to change so
much i don't want to
create um anxiety
over what's just an internal temporary
working document
so if i don't have to share it i don't
um i don't think you have to share it i
mean
to some extent it's it's you know it's
been emailed out to the division as a
whole
so it's up to individual members to
decide what they want to do with that
but
i don't would need to add to the website
just because it's been
well i need to think about that all
right please think about that
and miss rounds you did you get a copy
because we wanted to make sure we copied
you on the line by line so just so you
know what we're doing
i did not i'm sorry cameron i did not
realize that but
i would love to give her one so that she
could tell me where everywhere i went
wrong
i'm sure there are many places so
we are we are now back and uh
why don't you why don't you go ahead and
tell
us what's being shared here okay
so the chairman and i were trying to
come up with a place to start to go
forward in this process
and uh we kind of divided things
globally at the start
i was looking at the numbers and uh the
channel was looking at the staffing
so i'm going to start with with my piece
and the idea was to
start with the fact that we all have to
work with the ways and means
revenue numbers and those are the we
have to respect that process
that kind of begins um at that point
and we also needed a place a good solid
foundation
to build from and it seemed like the
obvious choice there was to start
with our current uh f fy 21
budget and use the adjusted authorized
numbers since that's that
seems to completely capture as kevin
pointed out to me
not just what was in hb 3 last current
biennium
but also what was in hb what was an hb4
so the second to the left column i kind
of i don't know what that color is
whatever that color is it says current
biennium baseline at the top
that is those numbers represent the
fy 21 adjusted authorized
values for both federal funds and
general funds
so that's the foundation that
that we wanted to build on so then
looking towards the top of the middle
part of the document there where we're
starting
in some ways you could say from the
governor's proposed budget
so his uh numbers
are up there as well and of course as
we're all aware
he started with higher
revenue estimates so we need to
basically
be coming in below that with the ways
and means number
but rather than kind of building down to
it we thought it'd be better to try to
build
up to it so starting with
the fy21 adjusted authorized
budget in conjunction with
the governor's budget i work to develop
what i'm calling a zero base uh
starting point and sharon go ahead i
just feel free to interrupt me
you're doing great all right all right
she's a hand up trying to figure out
when to
have representative nordgren interrupt
you yeah i know have us
start right in thank you um i think
uh chair weiler was going to have a
discussion
with uh nur major in ways and means
and i know there's been some discussion
with them revising are we looking at
their revenue numbers i was just
wondering
as a basis for our conversation if
that's happened
so so go ahead representative
at this point he hasn't given me
anything but we're going to meet we're
going to meet and that's all i have so
far so
nothing concrete that i can go go from
thanks
so so however in response to represent
morgan's
point it works actually quite well with
the process
i'm describing since what we're hoping
to do is to build upwards
from a base and we can keep building
um upwards as opposed to
working down and back up and then
working around like that so i i think
you'll see that this fits with the model
of
if the ways it means revenue numbers
either go up or down
uh we'll be in a we'll be able to work
with that
so so the process i went through
was to take these two budgets the or not
budgets
the fy 21 adjusted authorized which i'll
stop i'll start referring to just as
fy21 but that's what i mean when i say
fy21
combine that base with the governor's
budget which i was viewing as the
spreadsheet that we all received in
addition to the monster
uh pdf book that showed his budget as
well
and i just did a really simple and it
was just a numbers game i wasn't
i wasn't playing anything with what was
going on um
i was just looking at the look at the
numbers between those two budgets
and when things were kind of like we did
this morning when we were talking about
federal funds
quite a bit if a department had only
i just took those over from the
governor's budget figuring that
they probably were the most current and
and and karen had
they all worked basically for the the uh
the budget going forward and worked in
light of any changes that might have
taken place in federal funds
requirements and that sort of thing
then i looked at comparisons so if that
if it was more than just
general funds i also looked at the
uh general funds and the general funds
in one and the governor's budget were
lower i would also move
the governor's budget over again the
thinking was that
his budget was more current with the
department's thinking
so i was biased towards trying to
support
uh that current budget where it made
sense
and i also looked at even in cases where
there wasn't a big difference
so general funds were maybe a couple
hundred thousand dollars more in one
case
uh or another and then i'd bring the
same thing i'd bring over
um the governor's budget where the
current budget the current fy 21
um numbers not budget numbers were lower
i would bring those
over in their place so that's what shows
up between the two
bluish type boxes for
federal and general funds there for the
for the first year
for the second year i at this point i
did not build any increase in it's just
a duplicate of the
23 year the 22 year excuse me the 23 are
just the exact duplicate of the
of the 22 year and since we needed to
know where we were
what we had to how much room we had to
build up
i was looking everything as a reduction
from the governor's
budget so that's all the negative
numbers that you see on there
are the reductions from his budget to
which we can from which we can build or
build into
if you will and you can see the total
there is that
really wildly bolded bright red
number about 160 million dollars
well over the amount
of the current
ways and means numbers requiring us to
work towards
but again as as i said earlier to the
extent that those numbers increase
then we can we can move further up
the scale um so to speak
so let's make sure i haven't missed
yeah i think i've covered what i want to
cover regarding this
are there specific questions on anything
i've laid out there
so i would like an opportunity to
restate what i think
you just said but sort of say it in
in in my way to make sure i'm
understanding
what where we're all at that
that this document that you've put
together
is is not anyone's budget proposal
what what this document is is it
establishes
a baseline for the division three folks
to work together
to say we can go through the line by
line and look at the programs
and we have money that we can
add back to this baseline
and and and the reason we went with this
approach is
is because early on we took a look at
the simple fact that
the the governor's budget was based on a
higher revenue
estimate than what ways and means came
in with
and so we had a meeting with the
governor's office and
invited them to work with division three
to identify
places that we may reduce from the
governor's budget
so that we could stay within the ways
and means estimate
and they were very courteous but they
basically said
we believe our revenue numbers and we've
given you our budget
and you know the the house is going to
have to do what the house is going to do
but we're really not going to do
anything to help you with that
reduction process we may answer
questions if you ask a specific question
so so at that point it felt to me
like we were a little bit on our own and
we needed to find a way
to have a conversation so we wanted to
get down to a base to where
from that base we could go program by
program line by line
and and and potentially add some money
back
and the question was what's the base and
what's the
what's the amount that we could
potentially add back
and that's where keith has been
invaluable he went through
he looked at the governor's budget
compared to the fy 21
whichever number was was was lower he
took
if the governor's budget was was uh
within 200 000 of an increase he he
he took the governor's budget increase
of about 200 000.
so he took all of that and all of the
all of that math
and that's where you get to the 7.7
million dollars
that if you take keith's
view of a baseline the first year
generates about 7.7 million for us to
be able to potentially add back
now keith this is where i'm i'm getting
myself confused between the 7.7
and the 54.2 okay do you want me to pick
it up
yes okay so the first thing i did
which is what the champions of furniture
are the top two lines there
that is simply comparing the fy 21
budget
as it is as it stands to the governor's
as provided to us and that's where those
so just comparing those two numbers
the governor's budget is about seven
point seven million dollars in the first
year
higher than the current
uh fy 21 budget fy29 expenses
and in the second year it's about 58
million dollars
higher than the current year's
budget right not a word and then i'm
sorry go ahead
i'm back to understanding where we are
so
so so the total of
the baseline that representative earth
came up with
by following this algorithm
which was whichever is lower between
fy21 and the governor's budget take
the lower number with the exception of
if the governor's number is
200 000 or less of an increase go ahead
and take it
so so that algorithm led him to
an 835 million 568
thousand dollar baseline
that is not our budget proposal by
taking a look
at that 835
it looks that we have about 54.2 million
that could be potentially added back
now that 54.2 million in year one
pardon me in year one that's just in
year one
year one still has to pay back
the the fact that the ways and means
budget or estimate is less than
um the governor's so
so we don't get all 54 million to to add
back
it's it's it's going to be some number
that we work out with mr cain and the
chairman
and but you know let's say it's half of
that so we have about
25 million of that 54 that we could add
back in year one
and in year two it's it year two is
105.12 million
of which again about half of that we can
probably add back to that
fy 23 number so it's the add backs
that i i i'm hoping that we have
some common ground on representative
walner
this is more for a question for um
chairman weiler i think so i was never
really
clear exactly
how much below the governor's
estimates the house estimates were
and how you had a a portion nap
per each division so
i wondered if you could explain to us
how much each division
or maybe you didn't assign each division
maybe
maybe it was some other formula or
something so i just wondered how much
how much were we how much was division
three supposed to be reducing
uh
thank you so the initial
thought was it's like 70 million
difference between
what they delivered to us from ways and
means and what the governor's budget
looked like
and we had a discussion about that and
we looked at
how much the increases had been year
over year
and the biggest increase was in hhs
not so much in the other divisions
education had actually come down quite a
bit and
the departments that were in division
one
um not not a big change there
but the biggest change overall was hhs
so it occurred that that was where there
was the most room
especially from our discussions they had
this huge increase from
from 21 which they still hadn't been
able to fill the jobs
they had the money on the books but
hadn't been dedicated to employees or
anything at this point
so there seemed to be more room in
division three
to take the largest part of the
reductions
and so i did get i think about a 17 or
18 000 out of
division one and maybe only a couple of
thousand on a division
about 18 million out of uh division
one and maybe a couple million out of
division two and she said that's all she
could do
so keith took on this project
and said well you know this was this
huge increase
24 from one year to the next from 20 to
and they really still haven't caught up
with it so
there's capacity there that we're not
hurting anybody or any program
if we if we take a cut of where the
money hasn't already been
promised anything so that's the way we
proceeded
you have a follow-up representative just
let me see if i follow
so um division one had
an assignment of about 18 million
division
two it sounds like was only a couple of
million
and division three must have been 50
i never really assigned it i just asked
them to take a look and see how much
they could cut
and come back to me and see what you
could do
and division two said this is going to
be tough i don't think i can take away
much of it division one said you know a
lot of mine is the
interest on the treasurer's office this
general fund
and you know you can't reduce that so
once we started
looking at details of where the money
could come from
there weren't many places that
you know that had gone up with the same
increase that was
from uh 20 to 21
in uh in hhs so as i said that's why
it looked like there was room there to
say okay you were given
all these programs but you haven't done
anything about them yet or you haven't
found the people yet
with hiring freeze or whatever else on
available people so that
we were hurting them the least by making
the cuts
because it was cuts to program that
thank you representative nordgren
thank you thank you mr thank you mr
chair
so i guess the lurking question
for me is whatever happened to all the
money that
the department lapsed we know they
lapsed millions and i'm just wondering
how
this fits into ken's equation
thank you so so because i i'm i'm less
familiar with the history and the jargon
let me ask for clarification when you
talk about lapsing are you referring to
fy20 fy21
or a combination a combination
we know that we budgeted money they
didn't spend
and it was millions of dollars i was
just wondering how that figures into
to what we're supposed to be cutting out
of
the budget proposal in front of us
thanks
sharon uh rebellion organ um i actually
think i can
handle that okay okay uh
uh the fy 19
we don't see fy20 on this sheet but the
fy 20
number was was pretty solid because the
books got
closed on fy 20. the books were also
closed on fy 19.
but to get to the fy 21 number we went
from 750 million to 882
because as you've as we've been
listening
they have these fairly significant
vacancy rates
you can and and given how much money is
goes into the personnel line and the
benefits line
there's probably a really hefty lapse
getting teed up for fy21
and i don't know if the department has
an estimate
of how much they're going to lapse in fy
or a historical number for fy 20.
and and so uh ms rounds if you
if you have answers to those uh that
would be responsive to represent
norgrin's number or question sure yes so
i provided the lapse information for
fiscal year 20
and our estimate for fiscal year 22 um
on saturday
so i'm not sure if kevin's had a chance
to get all that information out to you
yet
um our labs um
for fiscal year 21 there was a further
so fiscal year 20 i provided it by
division
and class line for fiscal year
22 i provided a higher level estimate
because of course right now it's based
on
um on estimates on projections
that are still um in flux
uh but our laps will be at least 75
million dollars and i was estimating
that about 25
of that was uh potentially from
personnel which is about
uh 18 million twice you said fy
22 estimated i'm sorry 21. i'm sorry
i'm jumping out of here in my brain yeah
so
so you gave us an actual for fy20 and
you're
estimating for fy21 about a 75 million
laps correct all right at least just
i would say at least a 75 million dollar
lapse
representative while your hand was up is
that from the last one
oh i had a question for his rounds
all right but in this
in this last budget some years we have
given you an assigned
lapse percentage of your budget
in this last budget you did um i'm i'm
gonna look up because
uh it it's so important to what mary and
i
uh consider when we're managing
everything that i actually posted on the
board above my monitors
so our labs target for fiscal year 21
was 33 million dollars
so we're going to exceed that uh by at
least um
40 to 50 million dollars um so
if i may do you mind if i just add
something to that
also a little bit in response to what
okay so
uh representative norgrum was asking
about lapses
and i i think maybe part of what she was
getting at is what is the
lapse target for 2223 um
i do know that across the state
if i remember the governor's budget
correctly it was something like two and
a half or
three percent um so i do know and this
may be what representative weiler was
getting at
there have been previous budgets where
the
the appropriations are not reduced
directly
however the lapse target is increased
and the department is instructed
that their lapse must be at least x
amount
um and then we report on that i'd like
to say monthly to fiscal but you all
know that i have
a terrible track record with monthly
it's more like every other month
but i do report to fiscal committee on
um
on where we are with the labs target so
that is something that has also been
considered in the past
so representative while are you you're
short in a follow-up mode if you have
one
now i think that was the information
that i discussed with you the other day
about
lapses and signed lapse rates and uh and
so on so i just
wanted to bring that all up for anybody
that didn't know it before
and uh you know it's a typical thing
like
ms ron said two and a half to three
percent everybody's expected to lap
something
and with the events we've had in this
previous year and a half
thank you uh representative wallner and
then representative norgren
so karen um
there was a back of the budget reduction
in the um bill in um the previous budget
of 25 it was 25 million did you
were you able to take that off from the
first year of the biennium
correct so i um the lapse information
that i sent over
saturday i want to say our expenditure
lapse was like
30-ish million and then our revenue
lapse was another
around that amount so our total lapse
was about 50 to 60 million
so we talked with the department of
administrative services and the
commissioner indicated
that um our laps could count towards
that back of the budget cuts so we
consider that back of the budget cut
satisfied in um fiscal year 20 because
26.67
million so we definitely exceeded that
by at least 25 million dollars
you paid 25 million for the back of the
budget
yes that left you 35
right yes and our last target was 26.67
okay so you had 35 and then your laps
target was 26.
so you had about 10 million that you
exceeded it
correct that right okay yeah thank you
you're welcome
you have a follow up no that's what i
wanted to know okay representative
norgren
uh thank you mr chair so maybe i missed
it and miss rounds
uh what was the governor's lapse that
was presented
for you in in the budget he proposed
in for 22-23 yeah
oh i i would actually defer to kevin on
what the percentage was they didn't
split it up between departments
yet they usually don't do that until the
budget is passed
so kevin i don't remember if it's two
and a half percent or three percent to
total general funds
yeah the total statewide lapse uh for
all the parts was between two and three
percent in the first year and between
three and four percent in the second
year the the figure
67 million statewide and fiscal 22 and
thank you so did you just say 97 million
plus 56 million or something like that
so
it's a total of like 154 million
uh 67 plus 92 is 159 yeah
okay which is kind of coincidentally a
number that's on this spreadsheet but
so representative weiler i just i i want
to come back around and and
just make sure i'm clear on on on
something you said
it sounded like um you were comfortable
with the idea
that division three would need to
handle 50 million of the difference
between ways and means and the
governor's revenue estimates
and but that 50 million is is between
the two years of the biennium
it's a total of 50 for the two years
all right sorry to sorry to ask the
basic questions like that i just
i just don't want to get off
all right so so at this point
i'm hoping that the committee members
understand what uh representative erf's
summary sheet means it it means
that uh between the two years
if if we use his the baseline he came up
with
we've got the significant amount of
money about 150
that we million that we can add back on
a line by line basis
uh based on our understanding of program
priorities
and uh representative well
let's ask miss rounds first in case
you're gonna make us smarter what
what your hand is up did you want to say
something miss rounds
no i forgot to take my hand down sorry
representative
walner
well i guess i guess what i'm wondering
is
i just so i'm now i'm clear about what
um
was what um the chairman expected us to
do
was to reduce the uh biennium budget
by about 50 million in general funds
so now i feel really i'm clear about
that because up to this point i didn't
know exactly what that target number was
um and i guess i don't
i guess i don't understand exactly why
we
complicated system here of taking away
and then adding back
why don't we just look i mean this looks
like it would be something like
i'm sure it doesn't just break down
evenly like 25 million the first year
and 25 million the second year but
i can't understand why we wouldn't why
you wouldn't just
work towards where you would look for
those
reductions it seems like it would make
it almost
easier to understand
than taking it all away and then adding
it all back
seems like a lot of extra steps but
maybe
representative earth can clear my clear
my
thinking up well to be fair to
representative verve
this was this was uh uh
my my brainchild for the most part
and and not his and and he's just been
doing
the the excel sheet um not just the
excel sheet but he's put
a lot of time and thought into it so but
but if there's anyone default for this
approach it's it's
it's me because i wanted to get down to
a true base
so that as we add back
i think the process of adding back
is an easier conversation to have
than trying to go through looking for
cuts because every conversation starts
with
i want to cut this i want to cut that i
want to reduce that
and i in this way we're flipping the
conversation
to say okay using this baseline
where where do we as a committee see
our priorities and they our priorities
could be
in sync with the governor's priorities
it could be in sync with the
department's priorities it could be in
sync
you know it's really up to the committee
i think now that we have a solid
baseline
to to begin to add back and i don't know
if that's a satisfactory answer but
but that's that was kind of the thought
process
i'll take a crack at it mr chairman
kevin could you put up just like the
first page of the other document i sent
you
okay so this is what i also sent to you
this morning it's basically just the
same spreadsheet
that that i've been working with and you
all i'm not sure which way you work with
things but
it's basically the the raw data um with
the addition of the
the baseline numbers that we've been
talking about and i guess to
address your question representative
walnut i think it's kind of six to one
half a dozen of the other
so what what i've done in this very
right most column here
for the the what you see is cyan if you
scroll up a few
pages well i'm talking uh kevin
eventually come to a different color i
think it's like a pink color um so
they'll see what i'm talking about
so that color distinction distinguishes
between
if this is for every department um
whether it's
uh a governor's budget which is what the
cyan blue rec
represents or a fy 21
piece which is what the as if you keep
scrolling you got to keep scrolling that
cyan will change to a different color
it's quite a ways down there before you
get there you go so go back up a little
bit there you'll stop right there
so there's an example of what came from
fy21 as opposed to from the governor
so essentially as we were discussing
this morning we were talking about
okay which are the easy accounts to
[Music]
uh just say they're good so that'd be
really easy we just then we just check
them off on here
and we do that with everything which of
all the accounts whether no matter where
they come from are good or bad
so instead of thinking from the point of
view of the governor's budget
this gives us the opportunity to look at
as as the chairman was kind of
pointing out there maybe there's areas
of his that are not necessarily
our priorities and we might want to or
even the department's priorities where
they've been talking about some things
that they
may have wanted more so it's not to say
i didn't want to assume that the
governor's
budget was what we wanted absolutely and
all we had to do was take a few things
away from it
i thought it would be better and we i
should say we because just i spent a lot
of time talking about this
we better try to put in build up for in
on
with using our priorities so that was
sort of the thinking and i didn't think
it'd be any harder one way or the other
since we have to look at every account
so where representative waller did you
did you have a follow-up or
i did so how using this method
we've heard from the department about a
number of items
that they had as
priorities but they did not get included
in the budget so
how would we take those into where
where do those show on this kind of a
document
they they don't show yet because the
whole point of this document is to get
us down to a baseline
to give us some idea of how much we can
add back
and then of the amount that we can add
back we can
we can begin to target it in a way that
some sort of a column or some sort of a
way of looking at
so that we as we're looking at a certain
area of this spreadsheet
we can also see the priorities that the
department
has laid out for us that they had not
so that's a request that neither
representative irf and i
have made at this point i have assumed
that as we go through these line by
lines
we'll have our notes with us and and and
and
and the briefings that they gave us and
and we'll
and and we'll be able to look at that
information but if you would like to
make a request to
mr ripple and to miss rounds i i'm happy
to let you do that and hear what they
have to say
let me just ask do we we probably do
you're going to tell me we have this and
i'm going to say
where is it um do we have a document
from this round that has all of the
you should have that i believe i sent it
out and it's also
on our website i don't remember which
number it is off the top of my head but
yes it is
okay so we do have a document that lays
them all out okay
thank you is that is that document
in the same sequence as these line by
lines or
or in a different sequence to where we
still have to do one of these mix and
match
things uh that i'm not sure
i think they're by agency number i don't
know if they're in the same accounting
unit
order the other question i would have
represented earth when you did this did
you also look
at the uh 3000 line spreadsheet that i
provided
that had actuals for 18 19 and 20
and then had explanations for why things
changed
for every class line well
if you're asking do i have all those
numbers answers yes
was i focusing on those and putting this
together not so much
okay i also would want to clarify that
there's
there's the governor's letter that came
out recently with the your priority list
and then i guess there's your own link
party list but one thing we don't have
is the whole priority list starting from
the beginning because really that's what
matters right
that's just what kevin's talking about
that is what i provided
okay i i have not seen that i've only
seen the governor's
letter that showed another whatever it
was dozen or so things you wanted to add
in
uh on top of this so maybe that's in
that list i haven't gotten to yet
and by the way the lapsing stuff while
i'm familiar with it that only came out
on saturday just so you understand i
really didn't
i've been working this for several weeks
i didn't have a chance to incorporate
the lab stuff
i apologize for that but i'm glad to try
to add another column in
uh for the priority stuff if if that's
available
okay so we still have representative
wallner's
hand up i don't i don't know i'll take
it down
sorry uh representative weiler
i was just going to add representative
walnut questioned the process of
why why did why didn't we go through
line by line i remember doing that in
the past and it started off okay we've
got to reduce this by so much
and you the first few years you'd reduce
quite a bit and then
or you didn't reduce enough and then
later on you'd say oh we didn't reduce
enough look we're halfway through and we
haven't
reduced it in half so you start reducing
more and but this way you started with
everybody on an even l
level and then you could talk about
going back
without doing the way we've sometimes
done going line by line
looking for reductions so i didn't think
that i thought this was a superior
method like
uh representative nordgren
um thank you mr chair um this
question is directed to represent weiler
um i was wondering if maybe we could
uh tell division one they need to take
more than two million out of their
budget
it seems like they got to decide what
their number was
and i didn't get to vote on what our
number was
no it was it was division two that only
took a couple million
division one took about 18 million and
you know that's that seemed like a fair
amount for them
the other thing that we run into is is
since the gas tax revenue is down so low
the last couple of budgets i think we've
had to take money out of
general funds and put it into highway
funds
fortunately uh fish and game we didn't
have to do that previous budgets i think
we've given more money
to uh fish and game from the general
fund but i think
a fair amount of money had to go to
highway fund
because they're not earning the money
and they're still the costs are still
going up for paving and
employees and so on so they're they're
in a tough spot
because of the revenues they're dealing
with that decline
and have to be filled in by general
funds so that that was understood when
so if i could i'd like to take another
crack at partially answering
representative walner's question about
this
the reason for this approach selection
and that is
that um there was a significant amount
of
growth between fy21
no wait a second let me get my numbers
right
the the previous budget ending in fy 19
and the current budget ending in fy21
there was a significant amount of growth
in there
that the department had not been able to
uh internalize that should and and
a lot of it was because god struck and
we had the pandemic
and and we should we had a hiring freeze
and so so but a lot of the growth that
was
projected from 19 to 21
for a number of reasons just hadn't
happened
whether it was the pandemic whether it
was
working or worker shortages
uh whether it was because the
leadership was so focused on dealing
with the pandemic
that they weren't also able to focus on
other things
it was hard for me to look at the
governor's budget
and wrap my head around all of the
things
that that maybe really hadn't happened
or or
or only had happened to a partial extent
and so so what i thought would be
helpful
would to would be to get us down to a
solid level base
so that we could begin talking about
what
what has happened and what we would want
to resource to
have it continue to happen so
so i don't i don't know if that's
helpful but but that
that that was part of my thinking at the
time
all right um
i think we're where are we
we are at the point where i
had thought maybe we could do um
a conversation around which
which items we think we could or
which activity codes that i thought we
could agree on
quickly so we could just take them off
the plate
earlier we had talked about just
accepting
all of the funds uh or all of the
account
uh accounts where it was federal funds
only
just just go ahead and have uh
mr ripple move those off to the side and
we'll quit talking about them
that was one category and then uh
earlier today
um representative nordgren sent a couple
of
uh activity level like the health equity
line
the office commissioner line
but that was before we had an
opportunity to describe
this baseline approach so if you guys
want to go back and double check that
you're
that those are easy to do uh
approvals uh you know then we can do
that
on on thursday
but is on this idea of just basically
accepting
all of these with federal funds only
is there is there anyone that
no no i don't i don't think so so
so um so i think
miss ripple you know that's it's kind of
obvious but miss rounds and you and
everyone can just anticipate
that we're that all the lines that the
federal funds only we're not going to be
coming back to
okay so i'll provide you a list of all
federal funds only
accounting units that you can then take
a formal vote on
in a future meeting yes please i think
that would be helpful
okay um i so i
i think uh i think i'm we're through
with the agenda
that we had for today uh representative
weiler wanted to finish well
before three so he could get ready for
his next meeting
uh or is it for the good of the
committee are there just any general
comments we've
we've sort of done a bunch of different
things today and so
if there's anything we've done that you
want to revisit
or or perspective things this is a good
time to
representative nordgren you've been down
um i'm i'm still not sure
i understand your home plan of how we're
getting to where we're getting in the
end
um but i'll await more instruction
thanks okay so if if we were just
sitting
in the same room together what i would
do is i would pull out
with you i would pull out the line by
line
excel sheet that that keith is sending
us all or has sent
us and in that you would see what he
considers to be our baseline
and if you like that big line that
that's
in there then we can just all agree to
that probably
if you think the baseline is too low and
you want to add back
on that line that will be a discussion
for thursday and later
so it is you you now i think are
empowered
to take the line by line and say okay
accounting code 5608 or whatever
it is 5608 general funds are
a hundred million i want it to be 102
million
and and and that's where we'll be
talking
okay all right and and as you're as
you're actually doing it
if you have some questions just give me
a call or give uh
he's nothing but supportive when you
call him on the phone
um are there any other comments or
questions
all right so mr ripple what have i
forgotten
well thank you forgotten anything i
think that was the whole agenda for
today
okay so we're going to get together at 9
30 again tomorrow
um and uh the
republicans just for transparency we
have a
gop caucus uh at 5 00 pm
and uh representative erf is sent out of
zoom link
so all right well um that's all i have
uh thank you very much uh and with that
i think